Image compression
for Android developers.
>> CHAIR: I'm testing but it's
not coming up now.  What the
heck.
>> CHAIR:
I'm.
>> Now it's not connecting
Image compression
Compression for Android
developers
Developers.
Yeah!  Google IO/0      I/0 0
2016.
How are you doing today?  Good?
Staying out of the
sun? .  Fantastic              ?
Fantastic.  I love Google I/O.
This is the one time during
the whole year that the crazy
goal      Googlers can talk
about the stuff we do all year.
That is fantastic.  Today we're
talking about something so near
and dear to my art, and that is
data compression.  Art heart
heart,
and that is data compression. .
It's one of the most
It's one
of the most obsessive things I
get involved with.  All the
people standing outside, I'm
sorry there is capacity issues.
We will give them a T-shirt or
something later.  Really quick,
before we begin, I got to tell
you we've only got 45 minutes
today.  That's nifty
That's just not
enough time to go
through         through the
crazy image compression we need
to get done.  I've been trying
to diffuse some of these.  Has
anybody been reading these
articles in medium.com page.
Round of applause if you've been
reading the medium articles.
Yeah?
(Applause)
We're live, folks.  You got to
make them hear
it.  Second off is the Android
performance pattern videos.
Anybody watch these?
(Applause)
Thank you.  Thank you.  That's
fantastic.  Now, if you've
ferrin        ever been
interested in data compression,
ever tried to make an attempt to
understand the algorithms, but
found that the math is really
weird or it's too gnarly of
after concept or maybe it's not
presented in the right way, then
good news for you, because Alex
Hackey and I have gotten
together and written a data
compression book.  We took a
different approach to it, we
threw out all the math, you will
of that crazy, gnarly stuff,
and we got rid of it and how
we're to be teaching data
compression to modern developers
and engineers.  If you're
interested in deep fundamental
understanding of how to make
your apps smaller for users,
check out this book.  Deal?
Deal?  All right.
Business is out of the way.
When we talk about reducing the
data sizes of your applications
for your users, there's
generally two buckets that I
like to think of.  On one side
is your APK size.  This includes
all the stuff like code sizes,
language information, image
resources, layout data, config,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
All of the information that's
zipped up into a single APK file
and downloaded when users
install your application.
Now, on the other side of things
is all of the other stuff that
your app downloads once it's
installed from the Internet.  So
this could be many, many, many
things.  But it mostly boils
down to images and ^ cereal ^
serial                   ^
cereal ^ serialized
serialized
data.  It's a crazy domain we're
not going to get into today.
If you stay in your seats, the
next session will go very, very
deep into that subject.  So make
sure you stick around for that
of these categories.  That's why
we're focusing on our images
today.  Quite frankly, images
are awesome; right?  Round of
applause for images?  App      ?
(Applause)
Yeah?  I promise you, I will ask
you to applaud weirder and
weirder stuff as the talk goes
on.  Like who likes gum
gummy bears
(Applause) we have to have an
understand
.
(Applause)
Images are fantastic.  We use
them in our applications.  We
convey emotions and power and
information and all this great
stuff, but images also have a
problem, is that they're easy to
bloat.  They're easy to get too
big and too many resolutions
and too many pixels.  That
causes problems for your users,
because bigger images take long
irrelevant to
longer to download, which means
there are more bits on the
wire, costs your users more
money to download them because
they are on metered plans and
cellular is eating blare
their battery more.  All of
these little things add up when
you start bringing these images
down, which is why making sure
that your images are compressed
is good and as small as
possible, it's super important
to make sure your users are
having the best experience
In general, there is a lot of
different things you could do
with images, but as Android
developers there is only
really only four data formats we
care about, PMG, vector, VPEG
and WEBP.  The rest of the talk
is going to be opening up each
one of these formats, taking a
look at how it looks internally
and how you can squeeze out
every bit of tatted        data
from these things possible.
Downed        Sound
good?
(Applause)
You'll get the hang of the
applause.  GMGs       .  PMG
have to be one of the most
amazing formats in determines
in terms of
Android format.  They provide
amazing quality and actually
pretty good data compression.
So let's figure out what's
what's going on under the
hood.  Let's say we have an
image.  The way PNG compression
works is we take every row of
pixels in that image, one at a
time, process each row
individually, and what we do is
we apply something called a
filter to it.  Now, the filter
itself is basically a modified
delta processor.  Basically it
will try to subtract the current
pixel in the row from the
previous pixel, the one above
it, and do all this weird math.
The point of the filter is
simple.  Produce the most number
of zeros and duplicate values
as possible.  That's it.
The output of that is then Fed
into a very common, super-
everywhere encoding system
called deflate.  Anybody
familiar with deflate?
(One person applauding)
Get him a T-shirt.  We'll get to
you later.  Did he plate
eflate is actually
comprised two algorithms.  LZ77.
If you watch my compressor
head video, you'll see that LZ77
is a dictionary algorithms
algorithm that tries to
match runs of duplicate
characters multiple times in a
stream of data.
The output of that is then
tossed to a Hu      a Huffman
encoder, statistical encoder.
If you've been to CS101, you've
dealt with Hu    Huffman.  A
single line and the output of
deflate is kicked out to disk.
is very important.  In areas of
your image where there's very
similar pixels or very -- a lot
of duplicate pixels that     ,
that filtering stage will
produce a lot of zeros.  It will
produce a lot of duplicate
symbols, which means the LZ77
and the deflate stage will come
through and basically make that
stuff disappear.  So areas of
similarity will get great
compression.  Areas of noise
where there's not a lot of
similar pixels, different colors
that may not be adjoined to
each other will actually have
worse compression.  And that's
what you get with this tradeoff
of the filtering stage with the
deflate stage.
Now, with this in mind, we can
obviously see a couple places
that PNGs can be        can be
optimized a little bit more.
The first, of course, is less
input colors.  If we have let
less input colors coming into
the filtering stage, that means
we'll have less unique colors
coming out, and we'll get better
compression.
The other thing is actually
smarter filtering.  I won't get
into it right now.  There's a
different post on it, but
there's, like, five different
filtering modes the encounter
can choose on, and there is a
lot of math and accelerations
that go into finding that in a
way that's not going to take ten
years to compute it.
The other thing is a better
deplate algorithm.  Believe it
or not, deflate isn't
isn't the best did he polite did
he
best did he polite
best, finally removing
chunks.
You're saying wait a minute dep
late deflate
flate algorithm.  Believe it
or not, deflate isn't the best,
finally removing chunks.
You're saying wait a minute.
There       This should be
happening for me.  This is this
cool called AAPT, anybody heard
of that?
(Applause)              ?
(Applause)
In reality it should be
it should be crunching
them down as small as possible.
Anyone seen that hoop
happen?  Nobody?  Some people
Some people?
Someone's  's asleep already.
One applaud.  Get that guy a
T-shirt.  T-shirt for every clap
.
(Laughter)
So I want to point out that
while the AAP tool is there to
actually try to make your PNG
file smaller, it doesn't do
everything it could.
AAP tool does sphinx
things specifically,
analyze your PNG files to see
whether or not you're only using
gray scale colors.  For
example, if you're red,
if your red,
green, blue channels are the
same color, it will make it into
single eight bi          eight
bit alpha channel.
The second thing it will look
for is whether you're using your
transparency channel.  If
you've got a fully opaque image,
it will actually get rid of
that entire channel and save it
out to be smaller.
The final thing, and this is the
one that's pretty awesome, it
will actually scan your entire
image and determine whether or
not you're using 256     256
unique colors.  If you're using
256     256 unique colors, it
will save your image in a
palleted format, which basically
decreases the size by some
insane amount.  Basically all of
the 32 bit per pixel data gets
quantitized into a table called
a pallet and replaced with an
eight bit pointer into that
balance         pallet.  You're
now down to eight.
Good savings.  So the question I
have is AAPT is really good,
but how good is it?  And to
answer that, I had to open up an
application and take a look at
how AAPT was impacting and
affecting that application to
see whether or not it was doing
a really good job or if there's
some improvements to be made.
So being IO, I felt make
maybe we should do a call back
to last year's  's IO shed
application and see how well
I felt maybe we should do a
call back to last year's I/O
shed application and see how
well anybody look through the
scheduler?
(Applause)
Did anyone find the hidden
Easter egg in the source code?
Oh, no?  Then forget I said
anything.
So when we open up this file,
there is a lot of assets.  Now,
there is two things to compare
here.  First is the source code
files in get hub and the A
it hub and the A so
I wanted to look between these
two.  Because if AAPT is doing a
great job, I should see a great
change between the two file
sizeses.     es  .  I looked at
this random file, a 144 by
144PNG file.  That's 6K.  That's
huge.
hub and the A so I wanted to
look between these two.  Because
if AAPT is doing a great job, I
should see a great change
between the two file sizes.  I
looked at this random file, a
144 by 144PNG file.  That's 6K.
That's huge.  This is in the
source code radio possess.  When
I look at the
When I look at the APK, is
better but still massively huge.
So I said, well, hold on,
something's missing here.
Obviously we got some open Tim
meization
some optimum
optimization.  I saved it for
the Web.  It's a different
between file saved and saved for
the web.  In that process I
quantitized it to only use 256
colors.  You can see when I did
that, we got about the same size
as was in the APK.  We can see
that, hey, the AAPT did its job.
It probably quantitized this
to an indexed image.  Here is
the problem:  Take a look at the
image.  Does it look like it's
using 256 colors?  No.
So let's crank it down a little
bit.  Here is what 64 colors
looks like.  Anybody see a
change?  Let's go even more.  16
colors.  Still don't
don't see a change.  Eight
colors.  Still don't       don't
see a change.  Or if you do,
your eyes are better than mine.
from 256     256 unique colors
down to eight unique colors and
didn't see a change in visual
perception.  The difference in
file size, though, was huge;
right?  Because we were able to
find a smaller color size.
So let's look at a different
example here.  So this is one of
the big banners images that you
see inside of the application.
That's 49.            That's
49.5k k in the Git had you been
repo and 32K inside the APK.  So
some smaller modifications
going on here to the about
you
been
repo and 32K inside the APK.
So some smaller modifications
going on here to the had
hub
ub
been repo and 32K inside the
APK.  So some smaller
modifications going on here to
the.  Let's downgrade it
been
repo
and 32K inside the APK.  So
some smaller modifications going
on here to the.  Let's
downgrade it to 32 colors.  This
one isn't       isn't that good
.  You can see some banding in
the gradients there.  You can
see that some of the colors just
aren't        aren't looking at
true as you can.  So let's bump
that up to exactly 256 colors.
Here you can't actually see any
visual difference; right?  But
notice the difference in the
file size.  This is only 18K
instead of the 36    36K; right?
So this image actually only
needed 256 colors, but maybe the
source image didn't have that.
And this is the problem
with the AAPT cool
AAPT tool.  It does a great job
at those exact three things and
no more than that.
In the first case we had an
image that obviously needed less
colors, right, and could have
been optimized
optimized more, and the second
case had just over 256 colors
that if we set it to 256     256
it still would have looked fine
.  It means it's your job as a
developer to step behalf
past that and do additional
methods and reduce the files of
your PNG files.  Let's take a
look, as I said before, how easy
said      it is to mess this
up.  So you've actually just
take a 16 before this accident
he will by
a 16 pixel
by 16 pixel all red file save
as Photoshop is 2K.  That's 64
pixels.  2K.
(Laughter)
The funny thing right now is
everyone in the room is doing a
gut check about whether or not
their designers are using file
save as from Photoshop to save
their PNGs; right?  When you
save it for web, you end autopsy
the                 end up at
121 bites.  This is how it is
easy it is to mess up this
problem.
Now, the good news is you don't
you don't have to go
into crazy town with trying to
optimize all those things we
talked about before with the
different thanks of PNGs.  PNGs
open at this me takings is
open
at this me takings
timization is an
old problem.  Some of you were
alive in the 90s; right?  What
wasn't alive in the 90s?  Okay.
All right.  Old people.  Nice.
I'm sorry, "Professional"
people.  The truth is there is a
plethora of rules          of
actually, out there solving the
problem for two decades.  You
don't           You don't have
to do the heavy lifting.  Google
it and do any one of these.
Different stuffs        stuff
and different algorithms and
different settings.  But if you
just add any one of these to
your existing as set
asset chain, you'll get an
immediate improvement in file
size.  That being said, there
are some things that you can do
it tock            do it make it
even better in terms of file
sizes.     these two things
because I'm seeing them a lot in
applications that I'm opening
and taking a look at.  Aka, here
is the things you're all doing
that you need to stop.  So,
first off, if you can, in every
single way, try, try, try to
make your image 256 colors or
less.  It's a pretty simple
quantitization step.  You
staffed it and
You look at our main page
here, it came down 24 bits per
pixel, wasn't indexed, as    at
197 per K.  When we indexed,
only 73K.  Visual difference
here imperceptible.  The
difference in file size was huge
just by trying to take into
account hitting that index mark.
actually pretty simple.  There's
nothing crazy going on.  By the
way, that diamond down there on
that white actually represents
the transparent pixel color for
that.  You can actually do a
bunch of those.  Read the
article.  There is more stuff on
that there
Here is another one.  Can
anybody tell me why one of these
images is 139     139 and one
of these is 214?  Alpha channel?
Good.  What about the alpha
channel?  Wait, did you read the
article?  Oh, wait, never mind.
Cheater.  No, I'm kidding.
(Laughter)
So absolutely right.  Alpha
channel.  So here is what's
happening.  I've seen this quite
a bit in a lot of the files
I've opened.  So visually you
can see that the last frame is
what the user sees here.  But
when you open this thing up and
you take a look at the RGB
channels and the eight channels
separately, RGB has a ton of
data that gets mess      massed
out by the alpha value.  The
same visual image to the user,
but to the compressor we still
have to compress all of that RGB
data.  The filtering stage has
to be run on it, the output to
deplate algorithm.
defluffed algorithm.
The
deflate algorithm.  If we try to
mask out the pixels that will
never be seen, we end up with a
much smaller file size.  I've
been seeing this in applications
popping up a lot more than I'd
like to say.
Take a look at this.
One of the final things I need
to point out, if you're going to
go down this path and add in
some of these preprocessing
tools to your chain and you'll
tell your designers to not do
the things I just said and make
index files, you may run into a
really weird issue.  Let's say
we have a 216K and run it
through
Zoft PNG, an open source tool
for PG        for PNG files.  We
get it down to 185K.  When you
built       build it, it goes
through
through and it floats
bloats.  The reason is the
tool doesn't know you've pre
processed your image.  Again,
it's only checking for those
three things.  It will look at
your image and it will try to
make it into A, B, or C format.
Then it will just save it right
to disk.  The problem with that
is you may have made
modifications and obviously your
version is smaller, and their
version may not be.
To get around this in your
application, you need to specify
the option Gr radle, this will
disable AABT optimization all
the PNG files coming through the
pike.  Once you do this, it's
on you to make sure all your
images are awesome at that
point, which you're all going to
do             going to do?
(Applause)
Now the back row?
Let's try the front row again.
(Applause)
That's good.  That's good.  I'm
sorry the front row is winning.
Back row, you want to try
again?
(Applause)
Oh, they added whistling.  Come
on, front row.  We'll try again
later.  The live stream is
getting antsy.
Set this configuration to make
sure you don't           you
don't get bloating images that
you've already taken the time to
compress.  Probably one of the
biggest things that you can do,
though, in terms of file savings
is actually consider replacing
your PNG all together with
vector dr    drobbl
drobbles.  PNG are r   raster
files and you kneeled multiple
of them to get your images.  We
need one at in resolution and
one at this resolution, which
means in our APK we're ending up
at 5K footprint to present the
same image at different
resolutions.  There are some
split and up sampling and all
this other stuff, but this is
the gift  st of the problem.
There is another way to approach
this issue, and the concept of
drawing your images with code.
So that same picture, what if we
took a stab saying let's admit
a bite code and another code
that draws a red circle.  If we
could rate our custom DSL
language, we get this in one
byte per instruction, and 15
bytes to represent the same
thing.  The result of this is
bite byte
yte
code and another code that
draws a red circle.  If we could
rate our custom DSL language,
we get this in one byte per
instruction, and 15 bytes to
represent the same thing.  The
result of this is we can
generate these same images using
only 15 bytes of our scheme
instead of the 55k     55K we
were using before.  This is the
concept of vector image formats.
Right?  Basically we take some
sort of stream that represents
how to draw primitives on a
screen.  We actually execute
those, r   raster  eriz    e
rizing in a bit map, and we end
up drawing that to the screen.
The benefit you get here is much
smaller file sizes.  The
downside is you actually trade
off time.  It takes longer to
rasterizing these images and
getting them into memory and use
the hardware decoder and decode
a JPEG.
Theles the whole idea
.
and droid's  's vehicler dr
drobbl        drobble format.
It's a stream of paths and
colors and gradients so you can
draw these images at the sizes
you need on demand.
The question is, okay, this is
fine.  It's fancy.  I've got a
pipeline, my artists know how to
make the PNG.  Come on, bald
guy, let's get to the point.
What's        What's going on?
Don't
Don't rare
Don't worry.  How much could
vector drobbles save me as a
developer?  To figure this out,
I needed to take the I/O shed
application and convert all my
images to vector tribal
drobbles.  There is 270     270
of these       these.  I don't
have time to hand-customized
those images.  There is a great
tool called PO trace     Trace.
It's been around a long time.
It will take a bit map image,
with one bit per pixel, and
actually turn it into a vector
format raster image to vector
format.  I decided to run this
on every aspect of the I/O
application.  The results were a
lot better than I expected, to
be honest with you.
So you can see the top row here
is the source.  The bottom row
here is the result of the PO
trace application.  We're pretty
close -- the first one looks
identical.  The second one you
can see some rounding.  The
third one, pretty good.  The
fourth one you can see we're
only dealing with shapes and we
lose some color there.  The
hexagon is perfect.   S hexagon
is a really cool example here,
because that hexagon actually
absorbs #6    6K of our file
size.  The vector version was
only 961 bytes.  So even just
running it through here, we saw
some wins.
The downside, though, is this is
an automated tool.  This is
only a test.  We're trying to
figure how all this works
together.  Obviously there were
some failures.  We missed some
enter            some inter
interspersion detail, and
it fell over and died on the
algorithm
The result, though was a good
test to figure out what you
could save.  So running things
through PO trace     Trace we
actually ended up with only 153
files.  We didn't have to have
one for each resolution.  And
the result was actually 149
149K.  That's 84% reduction in
asset side      sizes by moving
everything to be a vector
drobble, which is a pretty good
size   avings.  Yes, let's lab
.
So 84 percent.  It's worth
noting, you can't run clap
clap.
noting, you can't run PO test
and convert everything over.  By
the way, there is a chance you
could optimize stuff further
instead of importing from SBG
and did stuff from hand, you
could get smaller than that.
You can get a lot of savings
here by moving to vector tribal
drobbles.  So make sure you
take a look at
it.  JPEGs.  Who loves JPEGs?
(Applause)
back.  I love the
begrudging pause.  We're just
here to stay out of the heat.
Pass me some water.
(Laughter)
JPEG files.  I got to tell up
JPEGs are crazy.  One of the
most impressive
algorithm systems I've ever
encounters.  It's impressive the
math.  Not frustrate
just from the algorithm, but
from the raw math of the
situation.  When you encode a
JPEG, here is what's
what's going O you take your
source RGP image.  The first
thing that happens is we convert
it to a special color space.
The reason for this is the human
eye, the psycho visual
differences in the human eye are
less susceptible to the
YCBCR color someplace
space.  The human eye is more
tuned to see differences
in RGBs.  The heck thing is
reactually next
next
thing is reactually reduce the
side of the chrome achannel.
The human eye doesn't notice as
much changes in that spectrum so
it doesn't worry about it.
After that we actually go
through and block up our image
and apply the discreet cosigned
transformed.  This is magical.
If you get a chance to check out
the blog post on this,
basically the idea of the
discreet cosign transform is
that any signal can be
represented by a sum of cosigns.
What?  It's a thing.  These
mathematicians sat down and
wrote it down on paper before
computers.  It's one of the most
amazing things I've ever seen.
Basically they can represent
any eight by eight block of
pixels by summing cosign
transforms across the space.
That is awesome.
The output of that is then
rammed into a quantitization
phase.  The quantitization phase
takes the out put of the
coefficients and a subspace we
can get coding mere      more,
which may be    be Hu       be
Huffman or whatever your
particular flavor of the month
is, and then finally, of course,
we egg to the output JPEG
we go
to the output JPEG file.  This
is awesome.  This is totally
crazy; right?  Way harder than
PNG.  Then why, when you export
an image you're given one
slider?
(Laughter)
All of this chaos is hidden
by    behind one slider when you
export an image.  That's
impressive on its own right.
Now, the question is what should
this value be?  This is the
JPEG quality.  When you export a
JPEG, we ask you what quality
you want to output it at.  What
should this be?  Let's take a
visual look at what Photoshop
would actually output as.  Here
is PS12, 100   100 percent JPEG
quality, 263K.  Let's drop down
to 11, 10, will to eight, you
can start seeing some will
to
eight, you can start seeing
some blocking.  Look at the red
parrot's  's head.  You can see
the artifacts, not as solid
gradients there.  Go down to
four.  This is quality four.
You see a lot more ringing
artifacts here.  You can see the
quantitation     ization
artifacts and zero.  Obviously
some color bleeding going on,
we're seeing some big stuff
there.  So the question is what
value should I choose
zation
artifacts and zero.  Obviously
some color bleeding going on,
we're seeing some big stuff
there.  So the question is what
value should I choose.  There is
no way we can support that in
any real pipeline.  The solution
is to not.  Automate the whole
process.  For that, I'll get to
in another slide.
The real solution here is to
automate this process and figure
it out.  That's not what most
people are doing.  What peeved
people are actually most
most
people are actually are
exporting the images at that.
The image men project downloaded
a bunch of images from all the
social networks and figuring out
what the export quality was and
put it together in a table.
You can actually see what
everyone is exporting things at.
actually really impressive,
because it means they're trying
to actually find the right range
of things.  The weird thing is
it's not as scalable as you
would think; right?  If
something happens to be brighter
, it's given these values.  If
it's darker, it's these values.
A little more quantitized than
dynamic.  How do we figure this
out algorithm I canny
algorithmicy
This is by the compression team
inth -- so to make sure that you
all can browns it, we'll
can
pronounce it.  This is gonna
be Boo teer             be Boo
teere              be Boo teere
oggly
>> In the native language it
means sweet bread to eat with
coffee.  In the Git hub project
it's a way to compare the psycho
visual similarity between two
images.  It's a way to say let
me take a sort image and
compress it and see how the
human eye responds to the
differences between these two.
How much error can we actually
notice?  You may have heard some
other terms in the past, like
PSNR.  Anybody hear that one?
SSIM?  Yeah, these are common.
Yeah, nice.  These are very
common things.  Thing of him in
the same fashion as that.  The
ability to measure two different
psycho changes as an image
changes.
The really use of the intention
that it was made for was to
actually figure out how much we
can compress an image before the
human eye notices anything.
Right?  How far can we go before
even the smallest perceived
visual change occurs.  When you
actually use the library, you'll
notice that occurs at the
1.0     1.0 level.  So when you
export at 1.0
1.0, that is where.
Anything below 1.0     1.0, you
can't decipher.  Your goal would
be, hey, we have a lot of my
high r        high res images,
and we want to find the image
export, this will help you.
Sometimes I don't want
perfection; right?  Sometimes I
want a little bit of compression
artifacts in there.  Someone is
loading something on a 2G
network or sitting in roaming
and don't       don't have the
right detective in interestedia
in independentth
in India.
Maybe I'm okay going above 1.0
1.0.  So detective
in
India.  Maybe I'm okay going
above 1.0.  So how would we find
something like this, find the
right level for some other
statistics            statistic?
It's pretty easy.  If we take
a little python script and run
image magic, we can convert
appointing          PNG at some
JPEG quality.  We know we're
comparing apples to apples here.
We run those two PNG files and
then through some random metric
we have decided based upon
artificial intelligence and
machine learning for this person
and     in this area on this
device, let's just say it's 2.
it's 2.30 random
it's 2.0
it's 2.0 random        randomly,
what does this look like?  I
ran it on the parrot images.
You can see really quickly that
we can find about quality 60 we
passed the 2.0     2.0 threshold
threshold.  It
actually was able to dive in a
little bit more and get single
step quantization, actually
found that at quality 62    62
we broke the 2.0     2.0
threshold           threshold.
Let's look at it side by side.
and the 2.0     2.0 score.  The
difference is 60K.  But the
image metric is so nice that you
can see very small changes in
the 2.0     2.0 version.  This
is blown up on a screen and the
life stream                 the
live stream.  But you don't
you don't have to
choose one image compression
quality for everything.  You can
actually dynamically choose
this and move
on.
Beyond that, there are a couple
things you could do by hand.
JPEG has the same problem, file
save as from Photoshop, 11K for
that 16 by 16 pixel block.  11K.
Oh, are you really sure your
designers aren't        aren't
doing that?  Are you really
sure?  Think about it.  Maybe
send a text real quick.  Yeah?
Save as gets us to 1.1K.  Still,
that's a 16 pixel by 16 pixel
image.  The funny thing is you
want to know what's
what's going on here?  Extra
data, met     , metadata.  They
have the ability to add block.
When I take a picture of the
gator, this is how my image
service knows where I'm
standing.  They have this
location base     -based
information.  That bloats your
image.  If you're not properly
removing this stuff as an image
serving application, that means
every other user who is
downloading it is grabbing this
extra bloated data.  Obviously,
that's not a good idea.
So let's talk about that's
obviously block removal.  But
there are a bunch of other
places we can optimize.  We can
change the down sampling, the
DCT coefficients are handles d,
improve the way we quantize,
great news, folks, you don't
have the                    you
don't got to worry about any of
that, everybody's  's got it
solved.  Google brings you a
pretty good handfuls of
algorithms and tools you can put
right in your tool chain.
The first thing JPEG ^ minute I
^ mini and
mini and M   M az
M az, they'll did he great
the image quality of your image
to get you just a little bit
farther and a little bit more
savings.  On the other two, JPEG
and pack JPEG are lossless.
You'll see the coding stages so
you don't           you don't
actually lose any bits.  Pack
JPEG works as a most        a
post-format than anything,
encode it in its own format and
getting         get it even
smaller than that.  You've got a
lot of web solutions you can
find, too, where you up
hoe        upload to some API or
some service and do everything
on the back end and scented it
to you                       and
send it to you.  I don't care
what you use.  Pick one.
Don't       Don't let your
designers use save as from
Photoshop.  Pick one, test it
out, send me a tweet and let me
know how it happened.
One thing, though, I got to say
this one is really tool to do
to do pie           to do
by hound.  I'll try to go
through this fast.  Hand
and.
I'll try to go through this
fast. .  Two images
Two images 175, told
175, cold           175, colt
modified, 82K.  The first thing
JPEG does is split your image
into a different color spice,
because the human eye is more
perspective to some
perceptible to some
loose than others.  We put it in
lab color mode.  We check the
areas of high contrast inside of
the AB channels, and we
actually just go file blur.
What we're doing here is we're
actually reducing the number of
unique colors, the amount of
noise in these chroma channels
so that when the JPEG c   cod
codic       codic comes
back through, there's
list              there's less
information you have to find
unique and you'll get better
compression as a result.  This
simple technique, going through
hand optimizing this stuff can
save you 50% savings on a file.
That's -- if you're still
serving a million files a day,
that's huge.
All right.  Let's get to the
final one here.  WANs of web
.  Fans of web P?
(Applause)
Web P, I got to say, is as
impressive as JPEG is, web P is
in its
own league
WEBP?
(Applause)
WEBP, I got to say, is as
impressive as JPEG is, WEBP is
in its own league.  You've got a
whole sweet of algorithms that
applies so it can keep up with
the loss compression that JPEG
does.  It's got the whole sprays
just like PNG.  It has some L
C77 and dictionary encoding.
The result is pretty simple.
Across the board all of these
open at this me says
timizations and
technique make it competitive
with both appointing and JPEG
everywhere, and it supports all
of these features as well.  In
most of the time it's actually
winning, if you check that out.
You get more features in those
file sizes and supported
natively on Android.  Round of
applause for that.
Let's get real.  Round of
applause for getting real
?  Weird event applause request
ever.  If there is one thing you
remember, some bald guy got on
the stage at Google I/O, trying
to get out of the sun and he
yelled at me for an hour, but I
remembered one thing.  One thing
.  This is all I'm asking you to
remember, that's it.  Nothing
else.  Just this
When you're choosing what kind
of image to make, the decision
on the format is super
important.  The first thing you
have to ask yourself is can this
image be a vector drobble.  If
yes, make it a vector tribal
drobble.  Easy, go to
lunch.  Ask yourself do I
support WEBP.  If yes, make it a
WEBP, go to lunch.  You're done
for the day.  Goon      Bonus,
sweet.  If you don't
you don't support WEBP, does it
need transparency.  If yes, you
obviously got to use appointing
for that.  If
use PNG for that.
In areas of very self-similar
pixels, the more photo realistic
an image, the worst PNG is
gonna compress it.  The more
simple an image, the better it
will compress it.  If it's
complexion, we'll go to temp
JPEG.  If we end up at pn,
run a tool on it, and hand
optimize for hero assets.  For
JPEG, correct the tool, hand
optimize where
you can.  You can get this later
.  Put your phones down, you're
good.  I'm flattered that you're
taking a picture of me, but I
can pose.  Anyone want a picture
with the pose?  Oh, some of
them.
(Laughter)
Awesome.  You'd be over here?
Okay.  We got to get back to the
AV people are getting mad at me
.  Most importantly, though,
this one simple thing.  Profile
your code.  Profile your code.
Profile your code.  Before you
make any decisions, before you
make any performance changes,
before you change your format,
before you put bits on the wire
that your users are going to
have to pay to download.
Profile it.  Make a decision
based upon evidence and data and
the best thing for your users.
Do not go laysly into
these                      go
lazy ily into these decisions,
because the people that love you
and your applications.  Profile
it.  In some cases, JPEG's  's
going to be better than PNG.  In
some cases WebP will be the
best option.  In some cases it
will load too slow and you'll
want to use a JPEG.  In every
single situation, profile your
code.  Find
the sweet spot.  Optimize for
your users in every case.
And thank you, thank you, thank
you so much for coming to this
session.  My name is coal
Coal McKinley.
le McKinley.
Anlis.
>>
Testify ^ did he have ^
definite purchase amphetamine a
definite P
you
Purchase amphetamine a
definite P are you in I in
and fast    Fast:  Put your
Your app   App on
a diet    Diet
Wojtek       .
Wojtek Kalicinski
>> Cosm
.
>> Hi, everyone. Please settle
down.  Nice to see a full room.
I wonder if it's because of the
heat outside or are you -- do
you care about application sizes
?  Who cares about application
sizes?  Raise your hands?
(Applause)
Anyone who doesn't care?  Yeah?
Okay.  Great.  Well, I hope I'm
going to assume that it's
really important to do       to
do that.  And I also hope that
you especially will go to the
session tomorrow that
I encourage you to all go and
see others talk about billing
for billions.  They're going
tell you all about billing apps
that will work great on all
kinds of devices for all kinds
of markets.  But today we're
going to concentrate on app size
s.  You know, if you think why
is it important anyway?  Why
should I care about app size?
What is app size anyway?
First of all, think about this:
We're here in the U.S. where
there's wifi on every corner in
every coffee shop.  We have all
those all you can eat data plans
.  We can down loathe
download as much as
we want.  I want you to remember
there are parts of the world
where people don't
people actually pay for every
megabyte they download.  It's
not easy to install apps and
keep them updated.  It should
matter to you as developers that
people install your apps, for
one, and keep them updated.  And
the other important thing is
that people's phones not always
have 16 gigs, 32 gigs of memory.
So they just kind can't keep
all the apps they would want to
install that they would want.
If you want users to actually
use your apps, maybe you will
help them by keeping your app a
little bit smaller so they will
be              they will be
encouraged to leave your
appraisal loan and not uni
nstall
app alone and not
uninstall it.
I talked with lots of developers
.  I asked a simple question:
How big is your app?  I wonder
if I ask you, just think in your
head, how big is your app?  Can
you answer that in five seconds
?  And if you thought a number,
I'm pretty sure you thought of
the raw APK size.  So this is
the file that is produced by
Android studio      Studio.  How
many people thought about that?
Yeah, lots of people.  And
that's correct.  It's a correct
answer.  It's technically
correct.  The best kind of
correct.  But application size
is not about the file on your
computer.  The user doesn't
really interact with the file on
your hard drive that Android
studio      Studio produces.  So
the important -- the other
important sizes we can talk
about is
the download size.  Again, if
I'm on not a very good network
connection, if I have to pay for
the data that I use, before
downloading an app I have to
actually look and think, can I
afford downloading this app?
Can I app           Can I afford
downloading this much megabytes
to download it?  It's not the
same as APK size
Then there is install size.
Like I mentioned, the other
important metric is how much
space users actually have on
their devices how much space
your apple actually
app will actually take off.
Not just the APK size nor the
download size.  I'll tell you
why in a sec          in a sec.
Third of all, the up date
update size.  You may think
people download APK, they get a
new APK, so it must be
it must be the same
as the download size only with
new APK.  That's also not true.
Then there is other metrics
which are really, really
important, like ram footprint,
how many memory your app uses,
how many methods are in your
app.  That's really important
for, like, if you have to use
use probably lots and lots of
other metrics for app size.
We're not really going to
take      talk about those.
We'll concentrate on APK size
and the four metrics I mentioned
in the beginning.
So before we start, before we
start talk about
talking about how to optimize
for all those four scenarios,
for APK size, download size, and
so on, just a quick -- let's
look at the internal what's
what's actually in an APK so
that we can talk about what we
can do with it and what we
cannot do.
And an APK is really just an
archive.  You probably all know
that.  If you hand pack it to a
folder or inspect it in an
archive viewer, first of all,
you will find the application
code.  So there's byte code, the
d   deck file, more if you're
using multidecks.  That's all
your code or what you imported
and so on.  There is also native
code.  So native library
compiled for specific CPU
architecture or ABI that resides
in the libs folders.  If you
need SO files and so on and so
on.
Then resources, a resources are
really divided into two
categories.  In the r   res
folder we have all kinds of
resources like
tribal      drobbles, PNG, JPEG
files, layouts and so on and so
on.  And there is also another
file, resources. .ar rsc   rsc,
which contains most of these
files, identifiers, and strings.
Also, this file can get pretty
big.  So we'll talk about how
to reduce that side as well.
There is all kinds of
miscellaneous stuff like other
assets, like you put any file
that you use as a binary stream,
anything that's not an droid
resource.  So if you want to
have a thumb bundle with your
app or game data and textures,
you put it in assets and you can
open it up later in your app
Then there is the meta folder.
This contains the apps APK
signature.  I'll talk about that
in the next slide.
Then trece the Androidmanifest.
When you work in Android Studio
and actually compile your map,
Android Studio gets all the
pieces of information from all
the libraries you use, from your
own app, and it creates this
combined merged Androidmanifest
XML that puts it in the APK
is if you actually do what I
said and extract the APK and try
to inspect this file, you'll
find that it's in another format
, in a binary, compressed format
.  So you will not be able to
inspect it easily.  And I will
talk about how to do       to do
that in a sec          in a
sec.
So APK, there is a folder that
contains the cryptographic
signature for your APK.  We all
know that's important so that
Android can verify that the app
was produced by you, comes from
you, it's gonna install it
securely.  And how APK signing
in V1 works.  The important part
to know here Android actually,
went very fine.  It goes file
by file, but on every file in
your archive, and actually
decompresses the file, then goes
over the full file contents,
checks it against the signature,
and if it matches, then the
signature verifies it's correct.
thing that we can do about this
changing compression
filed.  You can actually change
compression on the file inside
the archive and that will not
invalidate the signature.
Another thing that's
that's useful to know is that
removing any files is not
allowed.  So if you remove a
file, you will have to resign
your app.  After making any
changes to the archive, to the
APK, remember that you have to
run sip         run zip align
after any change.  If you change
something, sign the image, sign
the APK, then you have to run
the zip line.
We have this new APK signing
versions 2 on Android M that
changes things a little bit.  It
makes it a bit more difficult
or let's say impossible to
actually change anything inside
the archive.  It's more secure.
His signature is am body
putted over                   is
computed over all the contents
of the APK.  It's dependent
towards the end of the zip
archive.  Not exactly the end of
the file, but just before the
zip archive central directory.
allowed
.  And what's        what's more
zip line has              zip
align has to be run before the
V2 signing.  That complicates
things a little bit.  Potential
.  Fortunately,
Android Studio has made some
improvements.  I'm going to tell
you why.
Zipalign
has to be run before the V2
signing.  That complicates
things a little bit.
Fortunately, Android Studio has
made some improvements.  I'm
going to tell you why.  What can
you do to make your APK smaller
?  I think it's important to
understand those things, to
understand the role of every
file in this archive.  For
example, I said that resources
get pretty big.  So lots of
developers noticed that.  They
noticed that this file in their
app takes even ten megabytes, 15
megabytes.  They also noticed
that it's uncompressed.  So if
you create an APK in Android
Studio and you look at the
compression level of all the
files, you will see that this
file is actually uncompressed.
So why does it waste all this
space?  I said it mostly
contains strings; right?  So
text is compress I believe.
compressible
.  Many developers use this,
they go and compress this file,
and problem fixed.  APK is
smaller.  But what I want you to
understand from this talk, and
bring the take away there this
talking is some optimizations
are counterintuitive.  Not
always reducing
reducing APK size will help in
the long run.  For example, in
this case compressing resources
ARC is actually a very good idea
.  You should leave it as is.
It's optimized for run time for
running your app, the framework
can actually memory map the file
.  It doesn't have to decompress
it when you launch your app.
Even worse, if the launcher has
to read something from this file
from your app and the launcher
has to read your application
name, if this file were compress
the, then just to show your the
just
to show your app name the
,
just to show your app name next
to your icon, it would have to
be decompressed into memory.
That's one thing you shouldn't
shouldn't do, even
though you can.
And we're going to talk about
all these stages and what magic
things happened that make it so
that download size is not always
the same as raw APK size and so
on.  So, for example, a
compressed version of your APK,
so in case of this example of
the resources file, even though
we keep it uncompressed, when
it's actually sent to user's  's
devices, it will compress the
APK beforehand so we don't
don't lose any bandwidth.  We
don't       don't lose any bytes
over the network.  That's good.
The only thing is when
installed on the device, the
file will take up more space on
the drive.  Like I said, that's
actually working as intended
.
Also around the install time,
first of all, remember how I was
talking about the signatures
and so.  You can't change
anything inside the archive.
And so because of that, whatever
you install non     an app, the
first ask the most important
part of what's        what's
taking up space on the device
will be the raw APK itself.  We
cannot change it.  Even if it
contains resources for other
devices for devices with
different screen densities,
different CPU architecture,
there is nothing we can do about
it on the device, because we
have to keep the significant
intact.
So a little bit of space wasted.
We can remedy that later.
Then there was a thing that we
introduced in lollipop and that
was the new run time called
-- it introduced head of time
come spacing.  Whenever you
installed the APK, it would take
the index byte code and compile
it down into native code and
store that on your user petition
.  Again, this takes up space.
This is a derivative of how big
your code is.  The bigger your
code is, the bigger the compiled
code will be.
code will be.  So another thing
to be mindful about, one note
with M, we're getting rid of the
ahead of time compilation, so
let's say not a concern as much
on end devices and going forward
Finally, one curious thing.  If
you have any native libraries in
your APK, they will actually
get uncompressed.  Again, on the
user petition and will take up
space on the user petition.
Android can actually load them,
access them with better
performance.  Even though we
uncompress the native libraries,
they take up more space.  We
cannot remove them from the APK,
so that's space wasted.
Fortunately, started with mash
marshmallow
Marshmallow and above,
we can remedy that.  That will
be              That will be one
of the techniques we'll talk
about later.
Then there's things that
happened as well in runtime.  If
a user looks up the application
size in settings and looks at
the how app size is not just the
things I mentioned, it's also
everything you create during run
time.  Databases, cached images,
anything you download from the
Internet or generate locally.
We're not going to cover that as
much, but remember this is a
very important part to think
about, too.
And finally, update size.  Why
is the update size different
than the download size?  Well, I
don't know if you're aware, but
for many years now play store
Play Store          P
lay Store has been done
Play Store has
been downloading patches.  How
it works is, first of all, when
a developer up loads a new APK
on the Play Store, Play Store
will compute the difference or
the delta between the old APK
and the new APK.  Just basically
a binary differences.  Uses an
algorithm to figure out which
bytes are similar and only
certain bytes over the network.
Then the delta can be
can be additionally compressed
.  Finally, the client downloads
the difference, the delta file,
and reconstructs the new APK on
the device.  The final result
is as if the user had the whole
new APK, the new signature and
everything, but it's just
reconstructed on the device from
this patch file.
One thing we've been a little
bit vague about, like I said
uses algorithm and can be
can be compressed and so on.
We're really telling you what
kind of algorithms play    Play
uses for that.  There was a
reason for that.  So the Play
Store team always wants to
improve on that.  They've been
experience
experimenting a lot and it
wouldn't make any sense to give
out this information and then it
would change the next day.
But, actually, let me talk a
little bit about the most recent
play    Play improvements on
that field.  We have a new
algorithm.  We are using
VFDIF for the deltas.  We have
seen major improvements for
reducing this delta size.
For example, a major update to
chrome,         chrome camp
chrome      Chrome,
like from a certain version to
newer one used to take 22 megs
or almost 23 megs on the
previous algorithms.  With the
new one it's down to 13 megs
megs.  With a minor update, the
difference is a little bit,
again, from 15 megs to 3 megs.
Imagine instead of downloading a
whole tens of megabytes, whole
package of Chrome, you download
only three megs to have a new
version installed on your device
.
From other news, we've also
introduced patching and
compression for the
APK compression files.  That's
mostly used for games, but it's
super important.  That's because
games usually have lots of at
the accident                 at
the accident tours
of text you're
of textures.  It
can be a gigabyte in size.
From version to version you have
to download over and over and
over a gig, a gig, a gig.  Lots
of bandwidth wasted.  We are now
saying over a peta byte of debt
of data thanks to that
I can talk to the developers
about that.  You will be
You will be happy you have
smaller update sizes, but what's
what's really important
is to show the benefits to users
.
Play Store will show download
size instead of APK size.  In
the case of an update, users
will only see the update size.
Users will be more happy.  They
will see the benefits of all
your hard work of all the work
of the Play Store People
people do.  It's great.
Play Store is just one component
.  They can only do so much on
the server side, especially with
the signing that has to be left
intact.  So we also have some
improvements in Android Studio
2.    2.2, which is          ,
which is out in preview now.  So
they have been working on the
whole packaging subsystem and
optimizing it to create APK
files that are actually better
for computing those delta
updates.  First of all, they
started searching files in the
archive so that things don't
don't move around a bit,
because then the algorithm --
the delta algorithms get
confused and can figure out the
most app at this
most optimal solutions.  They
zero out timestamps and use less
space and comments and so on.
Finally, they're introducing the
option to store uncompressed
native codes.  So SO files.
I already told you about that.
I will get to that later in the
presentation
.
So what you can do, if you want
to actually measure -- if your
efforts of what Android Studio
is doing any good for your
update size.  I'm happy to say
we finally released a tool that
will help you estimate and let
me stress that estimate the
update size.  Again, there may
be    be new algorithms.  There
may be experiments that are
going on.  But this will give
you a good estimate on the
current algorithms and how they
work for your APK.  Basically
you're running against an old
APK, new APK, you see the size
difference, and you can see if
any changes you make make sense
for that
.
So now moving on to the second
section, which is kind of like a
tips recipe how to make your
APK smaller.  Let's go through
some of those things.  First of
all, how many of you had red my
articles on medium on keeping
APK size low?  Some of you.
Okay.  Let me first explain one
point of contention about using
compression for the People APK.
In the articled s I actually
wrote people
APK.
In the articles I actually
wrote you can reduce the size of
APK by using better compression
method, Zopply, completed
reated by Google engineers.
It did -- Zopfli.  Nothing much
changes for users.  They were
decompressed just as fast
.  Currently we advise against
using so fly      Zopfli for APK
.  Some users wrote to me that
certain versions of Android
might
have had a problem with Zopfli
compressed APK, they threw an
exception.  That's one thing.
Another thing is they take an
awful lot of time to compress on
your computer.  You
don't           You don't make a
release every five minutes, so
it's not that big of a deal, but
the next thing is really,
really important.  So like I
said, the Play Store team likes
experimenting with stuff.
Actually, using Zopfli, because
it's so rehearse
inventive,
resource inventive, it might
actually in the future make new
kinds of differential updates
impossible.
So if you read my articles, if
you weren go              you
were thinking of using Zopfli,
forget about it.  Just don't
don't.  Especially since
the new packaging system in
Android Studio constitutional
experiments with come pretty
compressing files in
your archives, and the best use
of the compression for the
files.  So that's also something
you in Android Studio 2.    2.2
have been to the session just
before?  Cole's  's session just
before?
So I'm just going to do a quick
recap.  Remember that you can
always pre-op at this myself
your images
preoptimize
your images.  In our build tools
don't always do the best job of
figuring out the best
compression for images, the best
optimization they can make.
You are free to use external
tools to preprocess images in
your drobble folders.  They
might be a lot more      more
for that.  Just remember that
you used to have to add these
lines to your bill patrol grade
bill.gr radle.
It had its own optimizer that
if you preprocess an image
then they could actually make
it a little bit bigger.  So
awable
folders.  They might be a lot
more for that.  Just remember
that you used to have to add
these lines to your bill.gradle.
It had its own optimizer that
if you preprocess an image then
they could actually make it a
little bit bigger.  So.    I'm
happy to say I've talked to the
people at Android Studio.  They
promised me this will be fixed
for Android 2.    2.2.  So you
will -- the build tools will be
smart enough to figure that out
One very easy
win you can have is so fly
is so fly.  It's okay to
use images.  You can use it for
files.  It's completely the same
.  The images look the same.
They work as fast and it's an
easy win for a file size
.
WebP is another image format
developed at Google, gives about
30% more images        image
sizes than jngs.
than JPEGs.  Support for WebP
was supported in Android 4.0
4.0, but only to replace JPEGs
for PNG images with no
transparency.  Only Android 4.
4.2.      4.2.4.
4.2.4.12 had new formats
including lossless and
transparent.
Then you can replace all your
PNGs.
Also, remember to use the server
side.  This is really the
biggest win.  If you're
uploading a lot of images, if
you know it's on Android, your
server can generate WebP instead
of jng JPEG             of JPEG
s.  You will save a lot of space
on the device if you cache
those images
.
If you can, on Android 5.0
5.0, of course           , of
course, use vector drobbles.
Compresses very about       well
.  It's just amazing for icons
previous         .  Previous
versions before 5.0     5.0, you
can use vector drobbles.
Sometimes in an void
in Android Studio
and you add them to these
studio, during your building APK
, it will generate those PNGs
for you, for those older devices
who kind of use vector draw
some able     able
drawable.
After that we got vector
drawable
awables.
Sometimes in Android Studio
and you add them to these
studio, during your building
APK, it will generate those PNGs
for you, for those older
devices who kind of use vector
drawable.
After that we got vector
drawable.  There is more on to
it.  I suggest you go to Chris
bang    Bang's
's seminar.
Vector drawable are great.  You
can do lots of complex shapes in
vehicler drawables
in vector drawables,
but they're not always
usable.  They're great for
simple shapes like button back
backgrounds, borders,
gradients, superoptimized.  If
you can use a shape drawable,
please do.
This was a quick recap of what
Cole was talking about an hour
ago here on the stage.  Since
everything is recorded, I
encourage you who haven't been
able to attend the session or
those of you watching online to
go ahead and check out this
session on image compression.
So that's what we can do for the
resources.  But what about
code?  Really, with your code,
with the size of your code,
there's one thing I want to tell
you.  Use proceed guard.
Use pro guard.
You will hate it, but use it.
It's very easy to add to your
build grade he will file and
then things will break
file and then things will
break.  There is a new way of
using the built-in ^ sling ^
shrink                shrinker,
it enables pro Garrod
pro guard and you can use pro
guard false, but it will do not
all the things that pro guard
does, but it removes classes.
It doesn't obfuscate, but anyway
, whichever option you decide to
use, you don't           you
don't have this notion of pro
guard configuration files
Proguard
and you can use Proguard false,
but it will do not all the
things that Proguard does, but
it removes classes.  It doesn't
obfuscate, but anyway, whichever
option you decide to use, you
don't have this notion of
Proguard configuration files
files.  In the Android app, for
example, the built in
built in Proguard file already
has rules that keep all the
setters and getters on your
views for the animation work.
Otherwise they will be
they will be
optimized away and your apple
break.  If
your apple break.
app will break.  In your
build folders in the Android
Studio there is an generated
file by AAPT.  It looks at your
Androidmanifest.  It generates
rules for your activities, for
your views that you are using in
the layouts.  Again, by looking
at those and by looking at the
default Proguard file you can
learn a lot and start writing
your own
.
And there's also another easy
way.  If you know you're doing
something in your code that will
People        be
code that will
be optimized because you
accessed it, reflection, use the
new build tools, Proguard will
leave it as it is.  Will      It
will not be removed from your
code.
If you're writing libraries,
for other users or just
libraries that are components in
your app, sometimes those
libraries just need their own
proceed             own Proguard
rules so when someone uses them
they don't       don't break
the app.  Be a good citizen.  If
you're writing a library, if it
needs Proguard, you can put
your own Proguard consideration
in your library, and anyone who
imports it, it will just work.
can't always remove code because
you don't           you don't
need it.  So sometimes you
actually need the things you're
adding to your project, but it's
not easy to keep track of all
the libraries that bring in
other libraries and other
libraries and so on.  So we call
these trance        transitive
dependencies.  If you bring one
to your gradle file, it may
bring in lots of those
transitive dependencies.  There
is a code command line for
gradle that will let you see a
tree of all those dependencies
you bring in.  Here the only
other devices, just be aware of
what you're using and what kind
of libraries you're pulling in,
and make the right decisions by
looking at this.
And if you're still not sure if
what's        what's inside your
APK, what kind of classes
finally make it through the
Proguard, through the
optimizations, through pulling
in other libraries, there is a
tool that we open sourced
recently called classy
Classy shark     Shark.  It's
basically an APK file.  It will
show you all the packages, it
will do grade          do great
for debugging Proguard if you
enable it for your app.  Let me
tell you.  I really encourage
you to try it.
So we have Proguard for byte
coat.  But if you go through
this pain of enabling Proguard,
you actually get one more very
important thing.  And that's the
resource shrinker.  Once you
have Proguard enabled you'll get
another option called shinning
shrink resources and
it will figure out which
resources in your app are
actually elevens
referenced from the code that's
left after Proguard runs its
course.  And it can remove any
resource that is unused in your
code, which is pretty awesome.
Again, it has a consideration
a
consideration, so you can add
this, really, on any resource
file or any XML resource in your
resource folder.  Just add this
tools keep or tools discard
attributes and you can make sure
that if there are resources
that you want to have in your
APK, or if you explicitly want
to remove something from your
APK, that's where you
configure it.
So a little bit like Proguard
rules only for resources.
Then sometimes it happens that
if you pull in a library, even
like Google play services
Play
Services                    Google
Play Services, or support
library, we offer
translation for many languages.
What if you just need for one
language or two languages.  If
you know there will be
there will be no
users of your app or that you
don't           you don't manage
translations for other
languages, then you don't
you don't really need
all those resources from those
other libraries, like the
support library for all those
other languages that you
do not support.
So just use r   res and put the
languages in the example that
you want to make it into your
APK and the rest will be simply
removed.  One side note here,
there's allotted of
there's a lot of
tips about using this for
stripping resources for other
densities.  That was supported a
long time ago in ancient versus
of our gradle plug-in.  You
can't really specify many
densities here.  So don't
don't use this for densities
unless you specify only
one.
That he is very advance usage.
We have resources, but there is
one very, very advance technique
that probably not many people
are aware of.  That's the
problem of sparse resource could
not figures    s
resource
con figures
resource configs, if you know
your resource is bloated and
very big, you don't
you don't know why.  It's worth
trying to gig out if maybe that
is your problem figure
figure
out if maybe that is your
problem.  It's not very simple.
So I'm not going to teach up
how resources file format works,
but let me he will         tell
you this is a big over
simplification.  Hopefully it
will get the point across.
Imagine you have an app that has
five strings.  The strings are
in the spring        string
pool.  They take up some memory.
You have your default config.
you get a new string.  This new
feature only works for version
21 and above.  So you have a
config.  You create a new folder
under your resource with v
v21.  You're just switching this
feature to new feature in that
config.  Well, it shouldn't
it should take up
space for only one string;
right?  But it actually has to
keep no industries on all the
positions for other strings that
you're not using in this config
.  So you lose a lot of space.
It still takes up a lot of space
, even highway you're just using
though
^
in this config.  So you lose a
lot of space.  It still takes
up a lot of space, even though
you're just.  These bytes, who
cares about bytes, but if you
have an app that has 3,000
strings, if you have 50
transformations and there is a
lot of apps, like among the top
100 apps in the Play Store, I'm
sure lots of them have even more
than that.
The cost of adding a single
string for v       for v21, for
example, that's translated for
50 languages would give you
you 600     600 kill owe mites
bytes.  That's something we
can work
with
o
bytes.  That's something we can
work with.  You can shrink your
file a lot.  How do you know
you're doing this?  It's not
very easy to guess which strings
do I remove.  We recently open
sourced a tool called ARC blamer
Blamer.  It's on Git hub.
I'll post those later.  Don't
Don't worry
Don't on the spaces for this
talk.  It's a command line tool.
You run your APK through it
and you get a CSV file.  You
upload to sheets or some other
program for that.  It gives you
have this kind of nice overview
of where the resources are in
your application.
And if you sort that by the no
entries column, then you can
find which configs are the most
sparse in your app.  Which
configs waste the most space?
In this example, if you look at
the rightmost column, I can
identify that the string that's
called apps list, you know, it's
wasting almost 200 kilobytes in
my app.  200 kilobytes is not a
lot, but if I remove this one,
I'm saving one meg bite for this
file.                    yte
for this file.  And you can
remove a lot of unneeded data
from your resources
.  Some of our apps remove two
and a half megs by just removing
three strings.  So that's
pretty big savings.
So there's that.  Let me just
say that it really works for
only big apps.  If your app is
not really huge with lots of
configurations and so on, then
probably you won't get anything
from that.
Finally, getting to the native
libraries that I mentioned so
many times already.  So since
Android 6.0     6.0
marshmallow
Marshmallow, we have this
attribute that you can add on
the application tag
in your manifest.  Basically
what it does
, it instructs the package
install the system, to not copy
out those SO files, the native
libraries, at installation from
your APK.  And the other thing
is things just work.  So if
you're us go system load library
, you don't           you don't
have to think about it.  The APK
-- the SO files will just stay
inside the APK.  They will just
work.  You don't           You
don't waste this space that's
used for decompressing them
somewhere on the user partition.
But there are conditions.  For
this to work, the SO files have
to be uncompressed in your APK.
And the other thing is they
must be         must be
correctly page aligned using
Zipalign.  So up until now there
was no easy way to do       to
do that using Android Studio in
our tools.  It was just not
supported.  You have to go in
manually decome brews those
files                      c
ompress those files.  2.    2.2
does that automatically.  You
can enable this option in the
Android manifest and see big
gains.
If you're worried that having an
uncompressed SO file will just
bloat your APK, will make it
really big, that's true.  Raw
APK size will go up a lit
a bit.  Remember Play Store
compresses data anyway.  The
download size will not suffer.
The delta sizes will actually be
smaller.  That's because the
algorithm will be able to figure
out smaller algorithms for unc
ompressed delta files.  We can
live with that
.
Then I mentioned before that
there's not much we can do on
the device with resources that
are not targeted at your, let's
say, screen density.  If you
produce a fat APK, if the
resources are
all there, there's not much we
can do about that, unless you
actually split your APK into
many small APKs targeted at
those devices.  Android Studio
supports two kinds of --
producing two kinds of split APK
s.  One of them is density based
.  You can actually during your
compilation
get smaller files with
resources targeted at specific
screen densities.  Then you can
then upload to Play Store and
use the multiAPK feature to
serve them only to serve devices
.
And then there is the ABI-based
multi APK.  If you have native
lines       libraries for all
kinds of CPU architecture, it
will be            it will be
really big portion of your APK.
Second, you can split those.
You can have multiple APKs.  You
can upload top Play Store,
upload to
Play Store, and users with
devices and certain CPR will get
only this file that's suited
for their device.
The only thing you have to
remember is every APK has to
have a different version code.
So there is some scripts that
you need to add to your build
APK to make that work.  I
real        I really encourage
you to go and see my articles on
medium      Medium where I have
the message snippets.  There is
no time today on this session
to go through all the code
variance
for that.
Example density split savings, I
took a toe peek a sample
I took a
Topeka sample app.  It's heavy.
The original fat APK was three
and a half megs.  If I split
that to different densities,
it's almost two and a half meg
savings for everyone
.
Then you can do custom APK.  You
can
split things by versions.  If
you have some features that only
work for 21 and and a half,
for 21
and above, maybe it's time to
start thinking about splitting
those up.  It's paralegal
It's pretty advanced
stuff.  Not even wants to do
to do that.  Then for
games, you split by texture
formats.  You don't
You don't have to ship
You don't have to
shift all textures to every
device.  You can recreate
density and API splits using
variance in Android Studio and
customize it even more.  Then
for games most people will use
APK expansion files to put all
the stuff you can put in an APK
to separate file to download it
from Android Studio.
They are
Here senior an example of this
time, of a build gradle file
that will recreates the splits
using APK.  Again, I encourage
you to look at my mediumcal
Medium articles.  This
will be explained there better.
Go through the tools that we
have.  Since we have only three
minutes left, let meTest just.
Testing. mention  Testing.
Testing that some of the tools
YouTube that I mentioned during.
this talk, we are actually
building those into Android
Studio.  So you might have heard
the keynote.  There is a new
APK appealer in Android Studio.
I'm happy to say you will be
you will be able to
download that now and
play with it.  What this actual
does, it shows you
the compressed sizes of every
resource inside craver APK
inside your APK.
In your dex files, you can
browse and resources a little
bit like
ARC blamer.  Then you can also
look at Androidmanifest.xml as
it is in this form compressed in
the APK.  So I keen        I
encourage you to try it.  It's
an early preview.  If you have
any feedback, if you think you
will find some feature that's
missing use physical
useful, please contact us
and I'm happy to
hear feedback.
So thank you very much.  And I
will be           I will be open
to questions.
May 18, 2016.
PL9.
Raiders of the Lost App:  How to
(
(Standing by for the session to
begin)
)
..
>>
PL9.
Raiders of the Lost App:  How to
get discovered on Google Play.
(Standing by for the sessions to
begin)
.
(music)
>> Hi, everyone, I'm Kobi, a
product manager on Google Play.
>> And I'm Milena, an
engineering manager on Google
Play.  We work on the apps
developer team in London.  Today
we're here to tell you how you
can set your app for success
using some of the tools we
provide in Google Play Developer
and tell you how some developers
are using these services to have
success on Play.
>> The vision of our team is to
build powerful publishing tools
allowing you to launch and
iterate.  We believe that the
experimentation is the key to
success.  Throughout this
presentation, you'll see a lot
of developer feedback and we'll
start with the feedback we have
from Michael Ritter about why
they released are genius and
Gems first.  Quick publisher
time on Google Play is the key.
at the time.  Rapid iteration
and experimentation is the key
to success.  Our power users of
tools like Beta test and go
store listing experiments, we'll
show you how other developers
are using these tools and share
some best practices.  SGN user
tools and then they utilize
their finding across platforms,
this leads to a much more
efficient soft launch process.
Soft launching is a great way to
deliver value to your users.  As
a result, their worldwide launch
was much more successful and
this is exactly what we have in
mind when we're building these
tools for you.  Our goal is to
help you experiment launch and
iterate fast
.
>> We got similar feedback from
creators of ball and challenge,
they soft launch on Android
first because it allows them to
iterate faster and launch to a
better way.  This is exactly
music to our ears, exactly the
feedback we like to hear and a
practice we would like to
encourage.
>> So what are we going to talk
about?
>> So we are going to start by
talking about Beta testing and
some of the improvements we are
making to this service to make
it even easier to run large Beta
from your users.  Then we'll
talk about the best way to roll
out these rapid changes in a
safe and controlled fashion.
Then we'll go on to talk about
how you can understand your
users using user position report
and how you can optimize your
user acquisition using store
listing experiments, we'll also
talk about the importance of
experimentation if you're
looking to go globally and
localize your app to all the
global markets and finally we'll
an eye on the performance of
your app on the go using new
play console mobile app.
Throughout this time, throughout
features that we launched
recently or the ones we're
launching told or very soon.
>> KOBI GLICK: Okay. So let's
start with Beta testing.  This
is a great way to improve your
apps and games.  60% of the top
1,000 gieps are running a Beta
join Beta so we launched closed
and open Betas.  With open Beta
it's as simple as clicking a URL
URL.
>> MILENA NIKOLIC: Did you know
that there are many big apps
that are running very large open
Minecraft, Ub he is r, Google
search app and many others.
>> KOBI GLICK: Nice. Here is a
great example of a developer
that is using this platform very
very, very correct way.  Hoppe
helping travelers make better
decisions.  Run internal Alpha
test and go much larger Beta
test.  You can see from their
feedback it cuts their testing
and rollout time by half without
adding any extra work for them
or their testers.  This is
exactly what we had in mind when
we built this model.  We're
making it even easier for users
to discover and join Beta
testing.  Very soon users will
be able to join Beta tests
directly for your store listing
page on Google Play.  So if you
run an open Beta, you can just
tell users go to our page, click
it there, join our Beta, and
give us feedback.  Feedback,
used to collect feedback from
various sources and had to parse
on, users that are part of your
Beta test will be able to submit
feedback is private, you can see
it in the Google Play Developer
Console, it doesn't show to
other users and it doesn't
impact your app star rating.
Now, we believe that apps and
games should be launched in open
section on Google Play called
Early Access, and in this
section we'll feature exciting
apps and games that are still in
allow developers, you guys, to
access early on with early adopt
adopters and influenceers giving
you private feedback and making
sure you can find product market
collection we'll introduce 28
apps and games, you can see them
have, for example, read feed,
it's an Android first online
book club or we have Eva, the
founder who are parents and
sisters who are deaf created
this app to help deaf people and
conversations.  Then we have Leg
ork, the kids and family power
brand with their first ever
in-house mobile game.  It's a 3D
Lego set you can touch, twist,
just like the brick sets we all
grew up with.  Now, Early Access
is not going to be just for free
to play, never alone, a gorgeous
game created by Ely Media
researched together with the
Alaska natives natives coming to
Google
Play on Early Access, they chose
Early Access because it's a
great way to make sure they get
feedback from their fans and
making sure gaming ping
experience is a premium one.  We
are sure those changes we are
doing to Beta testing will help
you create larger Beta tests,
making your apps and games even
more awesome.
>> MILENA NIKOLIC: Quoa by
mentioned that users will be
able to give private feedback on
Recently we have launched a
number of improvements to user
functionality on Google Play on
the console, allowing you to,
for example, search your reviews
by keyword or to see various
breakdowns of rating aggregates
by a number of different
dimensions, for example, device,
possible to sign up for
authentications, e-mail
authentications, when users
change their review after your
reply.  I'm happy to announce
that today we'll launch review
analysis.  These are further
improvements to user reviews
functionality and Google Play
Developer Console and they come
in several different tools.  One
of them is benchmarks, across a
number of fixed aspects.  For
example, design, stability or
speed.  So it basically allows
you to compare how your app is
doing compared to other similar
apps on these fixed aspects.  In
addition to this, we also launch
launched unique topics, so
analyzing all of your user
reviews and trying to extract
what are those specific topics
that users are talking about
just for your app.  Okay.  Let's
talk about release management
tools.
>> KOBI GLICK: Sounds good.
>> MILENA NIKOLIC: Cool. So
you Beta test your app, address
a bunch of user feedback and now
give as much support as we can
so you can roll out in a in a
very
safe and controlled fashion.
One feature that I want to
remind everyone of is stage roll
rollouts.  Stage rollouts allow
you to roll out gradually,
keeping an eye on the
performance of your app so you
can halt in case of any issues,
in case issues do happen and we
all than they torques you'll be
able to -- and we all know that
they do, you'll be able to halt,
and only specifically if you do
that auction or upload a new set
you start the stage rollouts, we
select a random percentage of
users who become eligible for
this new update.  If you
increase the percentage, we add
more users to the randomly
selected set.  If you start the
next stainch rollout, we use --
stage rollout, we use a
completely different seed, which
means it's not always the same
set of users getting less stable
worry about that.  You can see
how developers of FDX games use
stage rollouts to confidently
and frequently roll out new
versions of their app.
>> KOBI GLICK: Okay. Since
we're talking about release
management, I want to mention
another feature released recent
recently called time publishing.
Google Play, but we wanted to do
better, meaning giving you exact
control on the moment your up
update goes live.  With time
publishing, you can make as many
changes like APK changes, store
list updairkts as you witch, we
batch all the changes and they
don't go live until you click
the go live button in the Google
Play Developer Console.  When
you click it, the changes go
live within minutes.  You also
have a changes log showing you
exactly what changes are about
to go live, which is a great way
here showing you how this
feature is super-useful for them
them.
>> MILENA NIKOLIC: Now let's
talk about understanding visits
to your store listing page in
Google Play.  It's very
important to understand where
your users are coming from and
sometime last year we launched
user acquisition funnel.  This
funnel allows you to see how
many visitors to your store
listing page are being converted
those installers are then
converting to become purchasers.
further break down this report
by, for example, user
acquisition source or channel,
for example, seeing whether
users are coming from places
organically or different channel
channels like advertising.  I'm
pretty sure that like truly ya,
so far you -- like Trulia, you
found this report to be pretty
useful.  Since understanding
where your users are coming from
ago we launched another
improvement to this panel which
allows you to break it down by
country, which is very important
localize your app in a more
efficient way and to take it one
announce that very soon we'll be
launching conversion funnel
benchmarks, which will allow you
terms of how efficiently it's
converting users from visitors
from store listing fiej
installers.  Stay tuned.  This
is coming very soon.  And once
you see who is visiting your
store leasing page, you'll want
to optimize, right?
>> KOBI GLICK: Right.
>> MILENA NIKOLIC: Right.
Let's talk about getting you
some more users.  To do that, we
store listing really shows off
your app in the best possible
light, and in order to get to
the best store listing, we need
to experiment.  This is where
store listing experiments come
in.  This feature has been a
very big success with developers
the feature.  We often get
feedback from developers, for
example, like this one from good
games studios that drives
significant uplift to their
conversion rate.
>> KOBI GLICK: A big
opportunity to get more installs
is optimize I go the top of the
funnel, your store listing page.
install decision regardless of
whether they found the app from
search or via link.  Before we
launch it, you had to use a
bunch of work around and see
some budget, how they had to run
can see soft launching on Google
Play, it allows them to better
understand their users.  Store
listing page experiments have
been seeing great success in the
Flaregames up here, 30% increase
in installs.  Running exactly
the way we thought about it as a
experimentation tools.  Expedia,
10% increase of installs
globally, their most successful
test was reordererring
screenshots.
>> MILENA NIKOLIC: Here are
some best practices when running
Create a hypothesis first, make
sure you know what you're trying
at a time.  Run your experiments
until they have reached
statistical significance.  We'll
happened.  Minor tweaks often
have minor impact.  Consider
bold changes, especially if
you're early in your start-up's
life.  Finally, keep testing.
The next major improvement may
be still to come.  Here are some
great feedback we received from
Jamie Berger, head of marketing
at Scobly, you can see how this
cr has testing of new and bold
ideas.  We're happy to see they
use this as thish go- -- as
their
go-to tool for marketing and
optimisation.
>> KOBI GLICK: Here is a great
example of best practices in
action.  We've learned an app
description that shows you add
value to users works better.
You can see control versus
experiment, experiments is much
clearer, plus 14% in installs.
Here is a bunch of great
examples from concrete software,
sometimes you just get lucky.
They run a contest for IHL,
hockey target smash, plus 70%
installs.  Boom.  It's great,
right?  But sometimes you
actually need to launch, iterate
PBA Bowling Challenge they ran a
series of experiments and every
icon you see here represents a
complete series of spermingts.
experiments.
They also iterated on their
description, screen shots in
order, leading to a compound
effect of 63%.  This is
incredible.  Now let's see an
example from Mixi, a leading
game developer from Japan that,
will show us how a leading game
developer thinks about
localization and experiment
experimentation
experimentation.  Mixi wanted to
Strike to the U.S., they ran
spermtz, tested icon, screenshot
screenshot, description and
video.  In this chart you can
see how they run the experiments
methodically and scientifically
leading to a compound effect of
68% in installs.  Store listing
experiment helped Mixi
understand the difference in
taste and flavor between users
in the U.S. and users in Japan
and helped them localize their
games much better.  Here is the
feedback we got from their Xflag
makes us really excited, as our
mission is to help you test
directly on owsh platform. -- on
our platform Mill medical we
want you to experiment and
iterate and we want you to do
this fast.  This is why I'm
happy to announce that last week
we launched multiple concurrent
localized store listing
experiments.  We want you to go
globally faster and have better
toolings to test localized
versions of your store listing.
experiments with different
languages at the same time.
>> KOBI GLICK: You're talking
about making things faster.  One
making price changes in the
developer console, this sucks
because lot of people have the
same price poibtsz to many
products or paid apps.  What
will we do about that?
>> MILENA NIKOLIC: I'm very
glad you asked, Kobi.  We want
to make this faster as well,
make pricing faster as well cht
I'm happy to announce that
earlier this week we have launch
launched pricing templates.
With pricing templates, you can
define prices across all of the
marketed Google Play supports.
Did you guys know there are 70
such markets now?  Yeah.  Once
you create the template, you can
link it to as many paid apps or
products as you want.  If you
make a change to template, it
gets propagateed to all of the
apps.  So for example, if you're
like Boca games and selling
multiple titles, at say 2.99,
you only need to make changes to
your template once and it will
be propagateed to all of your
app
apps.  If you're like Woga
selling products and multiple
price points, for example, 1.99,
maintain three templates,
instead of manually making
changes to tens or hundreds of
individual pricing points in
multiple different currencies.
Liking this feedback we got, we
hope rising templates will help
you move faster and get
successful.
>> KOBI GLICK: Okay. It's
important for us, you're also
able to localize your price
better.  This is why we also
launched round pricing.  With
round pricing, we're not like we
used to do, just converting the
price using today's exchange
rate, we also apply locally
relevant country-specific
rounding rules, so a please like
9.73 euros, becomes 9.99.  1.96
Japanese yen becomes 200
Japanese yen.  We are sure that
this change like the feedback
you seal here will help you
streamline your pricing
structures and make your
businesses even better.  Now
while we were helping you make
price changes faster with
templates and more locally
relevant with rounding, we're
keeping your ability to tweak
the prices manually in the
Developer Console.  We know this
is important for you when you
round
run short time promotion or try
new pricing strategies.  We are
sure that the new changes we are
making to pricing will help you
go globally faster.
>> MILENA NIKOLIC: Last but not
least, finally we have a mobile
app for Google Play Developer
Console.  We have to admit it
tuks a while, it took us much
longer than it took all of you
guys but we've made T we can
tell you this app is pretty
sweet, we really like it now.
Our new app allows you to follow
your app's performance on the go
and to do time critical changes
wherever you are.  When you are
rapidly iterating, you need a
power tool in your pocket at all
app exactly with those use cases
in mind.  Whether you want to
quickly reply to user review or
show on which performance of
your app to a venture capitalist
capitalist, Play console apps
should be there to support you.
obviously you can see, you can
track your installs and un
uninstalls and break them down
by a number of dimensions like
app, version, country, device,
so on.  You can also track crash
and stack traces.  You can also
see ratings and user reviews and
and also track the state of your
Lee lease, for example, is it in
in -- of your release, for
example, is it in Beta testing,
stage rollout or prod.  You can
also get awe thent indications.
example, when your updates go
live.  If you haven't installed
the app yet, please do.  If
you're still not quingsed,
please come to Play sandbox, we
would love to convince you.  If
you have any feedback, send it
to us.  We intend to listen and
add more functionality in the
next couple of versions.
>> KOBI GLICK: Okay. So today
we spoke about launching,
experimenting and iterating on
Google Play.  With the new
changes we're going to introduce
to Beta test, it will become
easier for users to discover and
you to build bigger, larger Beta
audiences and improve your apps
and games.  Users will be able
to send you private feedback
that only you can see in the
Developer Console.  The new
Early Access section will
feature exciting apps and games
that are still in development.
We also spoke about better
understanding your users with
our new mobile apps that Milena
just mentioned and a bunch of
enhancements such as bark
benchmark
to the user acquisition report.
Finally we spoke about making
things faster with multiple
listing store experiments and
price templates as well as
making prices more locally
relevant with rounding.  We are
really excited to getting
developer feedback like the one
you see here from Scott Rubin,
telling us how features like
store listing experiments
encouraged him to launch their
next major update on Android
first.  We hope that the tools
we're building will encourage
you to continue to launching and
We'll continue to help building
more powerful publishing tools,
allowing you to experiment,
iterate and make your apps and
games even more awesome.  Thank
you.
(applause).
>> MILENA NIKOLIC: Thank you.
Now I would like to invite to
the stage Larissa and Aaron.
>> AARON ROTHMAN: Thank you.
>> LARISSA FONTAINE: Thanks,
Milena and Kobi, that was an a
amayorsing overview of all of
the cool stuff launching in the
Developer Console.  You can see
that Aaron and I are really
excited about this talk today,
so much so that we decided to
dress the part.  How are you
doing there, Andy?  My name is
Larissa and I lead business
development for the apps team at
build great apps in successful
businesses on the platform.
>> AARON ROTHMAN: I'm Aaron. I
lead search and discovery on
Play.  My team is focused on
making sure users find great
apps.
>> LARISSA FONTAINE: As much as
I love shap court Round, I'll
take the hat off so I can see
you guys.  I talk to developers
all the time and understanding
how store discovery comes up
always comes up as an important
topic.  We know it can feel
difficult to break through the
noise and to help users find
your app at exactly the right
time.  More apps are being up
uploaded to the store every day,
through.  Studies show that more
users are using the same set of
apps over and over again instead
theory is that app fatigue is
driving this.  But what if it's
that users simply can't find all
the great apps that are out
there?  It's not only apps that
are growing.  The entire Android
ecosystem is growing entirely
fast.  You heard some of these
numbers this morning.  The one
we'll talk about here is
1 billion monthly store users.
Out of that huge audience, we
want to help you find the best
users for your app.  That's why
you're all here.  Today, we'll
walk through how we can work
together to improve app
discovery in the Play Store.
There are a lot of important
elements that contribute to
discovery, some of which you
already heard about.  But we're
going to touch on a few of them
again because they're that
important and because they
directly contribute to discovery
discovery.  We've narrowed them
down to the most critical and
we'll go through each of them.
Build something great, listen to
presence, and expand your reach.
Then we're going on share some
insights about how the discovery
shared before.
>> AARON ROTHMAN: As Larissa
mentioned, it all starts with
building something great.  We
want users to find the apps they
will love.  So a quarter of
installed apps are used only
once.  Wow.  That's scarier
unanimous a pit of snakes.
>> LARISSA FONTAINE: All right,
Aaron, let's tone it back.
>> AARON ROTHMAN: Anyway, this
is why we want to start with
building something great.  So
based on some internal analysis,
we found that permissions,
footprint -- excuse me.  We
found that permissions,
footprint and design were all
key components when it came to a
user's perception of a great app
app.  So starting with
permissions, excessive
permissions can actually deal
ter a user from installing your
app in the first place.  It's
important to remember if you
don't need it, don't ask for it.
apps where the permissions don't
seem to align with the app
functionality.  For example, why
access my phone's call logs?
Second is footprint.  Some users
footprint of your app.  These
users may be on poor internet
connections or have limited
phone memory.  This is
especially true in emerging
markets where there are both
phone and network limitations.
So it's helpful to be mindful of
memory usage.  Sometimes less is
more.  Third is design.  So the
user has installed your app.
Now you want to ensure a great
experience, so remember to limit
designed app is intuitive and
consistent and does not require
a user to hunt, guess, remember
or otherwise strain their brains
interact with your app.  One
tangible solution for making a
highly use I believe app simply
meanting
meanting Google's design spec
known as material design.  Here
are two examples of apps that
invested more in quality by
adopting material design, which
led to the benefit of more user
engagement.  It's pretty
impressive, for example, that Tr
Trello saw 41% increase in
activity per session by
implementing material design.
You can do your best to build a
great app, but how can you be
sure it's actually great?  More
than half of poor user reviews
are quality related, and a third
iteration, so we recommend
following the earlier advice of
Milena and Kobi and using are
Beta testing and stageed roll
outs
to ensure that your app is great
covered building and launching a
great app.  Now just because
your app is launched, it doesn't
with your users.  Listen to go
your users is important for
continued success, and I'm going
to explain why.  You have a
unique opportunity in Android to
by replying to the reviews via
the Developer Console and
building an even more loved app
as a result.  One example is Ava
Avary, who created a dialogue
with their users by engaging
with feedback.  This
responsiveness led to a 50% of
reviewers revising their score
as higher.  Crazy.  A boost in
discovery opportunities and
higher ratings.
>> LARISSA FONTAINE: After
building a great app and
listening to your users, it's
important
important to create a Play Store
listing that quickly and
accurately reflects what your
app is about.  You're all
familiar with the different
elements of your listing.  This
really requires some thoughtful
attention.  We've provided
multiple ways for you to
communicate the value of your
app and it's up to you to try to
interesting information, and
each of them from the title to
the description to the images
provide metadata that help us
understand what your app does
and who is most likely to use it
it.  It sounds easy, but no one
gets it right the first time.
This is why we created store
listing experiments, to help you
You already heard from Kobi and
Milena about how these have
helped developers over the last
year and the stat that 70% of
top developers are using
experiments is really incredible
incredible.  Developers of all
sizes are seeing real impact.
An iteration is key for store
listing experiments.  This
example from Rovio, they focus
on the icon and finding which
one with most impact conversions
conversions.  Here 12 different
treatments they exploreed with
various outcomes.  They kept
iterating.  This is what we see
from developers who are finding
the most success.  They trn to
continue
to test and refine and
understand user preferences.
Ultimately Rovio saw suggest up
uplift as a result of their
experiments, and back to
discovery.  Higher conversion
rates from listing to installs
are an important install and
help us understand when a user
is successfully gone from
searching for an app to finding
one that they think they'll love
love.  So now you've built a
great app, you've implemented
important feedback and you have
a strong Play Store presence.
What's next?  There are
different opportunities to
expand your reach depending on
the type of app you have and the
users are looking for.  Going
global and finding audiences in
new smarkts a strategy that's
worked extremely well for many
developers, so we'll explore a
few tips and tools that can help
massive reach of Android.  We've
actually looked at the growth
rates of apps that are available
Global apps grew 2.4 times
faster than nonglobal apps.  Now
Now, this makes intuitive sense.
If you're in more market, you
have a larger addressable awd
yerches, but the data really
proves it out.  There are a few
specific things to consider when
you're planning to localize your
app.  First, you should use the
dev console reports we talked
about to understand where new
user bayses bays bases are
growing and
prioritize those market.  Second
Second, don't just translate,
actually localize, meaning
ensure that you're culturally
culturally
aware of local expectations and
be ready to support your new
users.  Last, always be prepared
to test and iterate.  New users
means new feedback.  A developer
this is One Password, they
localized their store
description, their screen shots,
content and messageing inside
their app and we looked at those
app was ready to be shown to
local users.  For one password,
the investment really paid off.
After two weeks of work, they
saw 100X install growth in Korea
Korea.  This is really pretty
incredible.  By focusing on
local market users, they made a
real difference and in most
cases it's worth the effort if
your plan is to grow through
market expansion.  And we have
powerful tools to help, like the
to translation services and the
new pricing features that Kobi
shared.  So we've reviewed the
most important ways that you can
discoverability of your app and
some key actions that you can
take right away.  For build
something great, limit
permissions and focus on
beautiful design.  Listen to
your users, feedback is a gift,
use it to get better.  Optimize
your presence.  Experiment your
way to improve conversions
conversions, and
expand your reach.  Go global
and localize.  We've also
mentioned that all of these
impact discovery within the
store, so let's unpack how the
store actually works and why
each of these elements actually
matter.
>> AARON ROTHMAN: There we go.
I'm back.  Great.  So how are
users actually discovering apps
in Play and what matters to
those discovery mechanisms?
Let's start with how users are
actually finding apps today.
The top discovery channels are
Play are, number one, play
search, two, recommendations,
three, top charts.  So starting
with search, about half of
searches are specifically for an
especially important when name
lg naming
your app to be unique, keep it
short, and make sure that it is
not easily confused with a
similarly named app.  A well-
well-nameed app also has the
benefit of appearing within
Google Play search suggest,
which makes it even easier for
users to find your app, by using
Google Play search suggest, they
don't even need to type in the
full name to find the app.  Half
important to make sure you
select the right app category.
Also when you're writing the
description of your app, it's
great and important to be
thorough and complete, making
sure to include key
functionality and features.  You
actually a third twhai an app
can appear within irve given
search results and this is ads.
Play search ads are already part
of AdWords appear install
campaigns ask provide additional
search.
So recommendations.  Whether on
the homepage or right after a
user installs an app, Google
Play recommends apps
personalized for each user.
Although there are a lot of
components that go into those
smarts, I just want to highlight
a few for you today.  These
include metadata, app quality,
user store activity and web
knowledge.
>> LARISSA FONTAINE: The charts
are a common way for both new
and returning users to gain a
quick understanding of which
apps are popular in the store
and which apps are on their way
to becoming popular.  We'll
share insight into how these
charts are put together with
specific details on key
components.
Top free and top
pay charts are primarily
determined by installs within
the last 7 days.  We want the
charts to stay fresh and
interesting week over week, so
we've kept it short.  Top new
free and top new paid also look
at installs over the previous 7
days but they're buy alpsed
towards new apps, those that
have -- biased towards new apps,
store in the previous 30 days.
This is to ensure the charts
aren't established by
established titles.  We want to
help users find new and
interesting apps wherever they
look for them.  Trending, on the
other hand, otherwise fast
risers that have the potential
to make it onto the top charts.
Typically this means their
installs have seen accelerateed
growth over the previous 30 days
but their absolute installs
might not be as large as those
on the other top charts.
Finally, top grossing grossing
uses the
same 7-day trailing approach but
tuning our algorithms to produce
the best user experience.  These
are subject to change rs but
hopefully you have a better
sense of what drives top
placement in the charts and what
Featuring.  Everybody loves
featureing.  We define feature
ing
to mean the collections that
appear across the store, either
manually cure rateed or
algorithmically generated.
Quality is the key driver for
inclusion, that's why we spent
the first half of this talk
focused on tools and strategies
to help drive important quality
signals.  In addition to quality
quality, we also want to surface
fresh and we definitely want
users to find apps using the
latest Android features, things
that truly make their experience
your app is eligible for appear
appearing in certain collections
where users have installed
similar apps.  With an even
higher expectation of quality,
we have collections showcaseing
new and updated apps, so users
know they're getting great
experiences that are hot off the
presses.  For seasonal
collections and special
promotions, our BDM
merchandising teams work
together to identify which apps
to include and we also use a
healthy dose of machine learning
to scale our efforts across
categories and markets.  It's
important to note that within
each of these collections, the
recommendations engine helps
determine which users see which
apps.  The most important thing
is not that millions of users
see your app, it's that millions
of the right useers see your app
and go on to install it.
>> AARON ROTHMAN: Now that
we've revealed the holy grail of
app discovery, we want to leave
you with four recommendations
that you can do right now.
Number one, for building a great
Android's design principles.
Does your app measure up?  Two,
for listening to your users, we
recommend addressing user
feedback, especially when it
comes to bugs.  Squash those
bugs.  Number three, for
optimizeing your presence, why
not try a store listing
experiment?  And finally, number
we recommend reviewing the
market report and the Developer
Console.  So that's our talk for
today.  We are so excited to
have you all here.  We know we
shared a lot of content with you
you, but the great news is that
you can find everything you need
in our new app, Playbook by
Google Play, it replaces the
business guide that some of you
have seen called the Secrets to
App Success on Google Play.
There are a ton of great
features, but it's brand new, so
we would love your feedback.  If
you get a moment, please hop
over to the Google Play Store
and try it out.  And of course
we want to leave you with a few
helpful links, and again, thank
you so much for coming, from all
>> LARISSA FONTAINE: Thank you.
(applause)
.
(The session ended at 4:39 p.m.)
Test.  Test.
>>
May 18, 2016.
What the Fragment?
>> All right. Hello, everyone,
and welcome to What the Fragment
Fragment.  I'm Adam Powell, I'm
a member of the Android fragment
toolkit but I've spent a fair
amount of time with fragments
over the years here and
hopefully we can go over some
interesting information here.
So the first thing that people
tend to ask is why fragments?
There's a lot of information out
the API, gotten kind of familiar
with it and in some ways kind of
gotten bitten by it.  There's a
lot of complexity there.  In
fact, some members of the
community have put together a
few diagrams of just how complex
the fragment life cycle can be
if you combine it with the full
activity life cycle as well.
You can start up at the top here
some more.  Whew, okay.  Well,
we got to the end.  So the
blurriness that you're seeing
here isn't just because it's a
low res version of the image,
it's just your eyes glazeing
over
as you try and take all of this
in.  This is kind of your
reaction after reading over it.
is
kind of the reaction tharve has
had over the last few years out
in the developer exphunt, why is
community, why is it still
something that we're pushing or
promoteing as a way to build
your
applications?  To start with
that, we'll go over a little bit
Diane Hawthorne this past
weekend where she went into some
component model and how it's
really not intended to I
remember to impose a
lot of higher level architecture
instead intended to be a series
of entry points.  As a
traditional program you might
have seen in classes, you start
from a main function, run to the
end, you might start a message
loop in the middle there and
what activities gives you is a
smarter entry point, pay place
where the system can send you
other messages about what's
going on to your application and
these are just turned into call
backs on an object instead.  So
there were some other goals kind
of in the design of activities
as well, which one of those is
that apps always stay in the
state where you left them.  So
in order to do that, you have
this well defined activity life
cycle and a compact state
representation that you can use
so the process can die, come
back later, restore from that
state.  All of this is stuff
that you're probably familiar
with.  Also apps can call other
apps to complete a task in the
form of activities called with
intent and each one of those
flows is represented as one of
these encapsulateed units in the
over time activities just
started getting big and complex
and basically the way you deal
with complexity is that you
factor out smaller pieces so you
can compose them.  Back in the
pre-Android 3.0 days we had
these things called activity
manager that could work in
concert with a co-host widget,
so each one of these pieces and
each one of these tabs contained
a full activity so that gave
some weird pieces of the code
there in terms of how the code
would interact.  There are ideas
don't make sense of this kind of
composed model.  Then this
happened, and we're not going to
(laughter)
.
>> ADAM POWELL: So larger
screens happened and larger
screens mean larger problems.
So we have this idea of how do
you want to present these
multiple small screens worth of
UI that you may have already
built in an existing application
and then sort of scale that out
across other screens?  Is there
sort of a smaller unit of
composition that you could use
for that?  And so that other
unit of composition spoilers is
fragments.  So this was
introduced around honeycomb to
try to solve some of these
problems.  The first one of
these goals, though, was really
just to break up these giant
activity classes and this is a
problem that happens whether
you're dealing just with small
phone screens or if you're
trying to scale across many
different screen sizes, and it's
complexity of these kind of big
entry points that can kind of
grow to be these God objects if
you're not careful.  We also
kind of wanted to fix some of
these problems with local
activity manager for when you do
compose them in these small
constructs.  So you have lots of
activity level that just don't
work well when you start compose
composing it this way.  These
are usually things that aren't
quite as well covered as like
the core activity state diagram
but they're all cases that still
need to be handled in a general
purpose solution.  One of the
other things that we wanted to
do with frag mentz was to --
fragments was to encapsulate
navigation state.  So the state
of your fragments can represent
the full state of your activity
in a way that can be preserveed
through state save and restore
through a process step, so we
have things like an activity
local back stack, which some
people find useful and some
people don't, but manageed
dialogues was one of the other
things that this really tried to
address.  Dialogue fragment is
go that a lot of people do use
at this point and it's because
you basically get the state
restoration for free if you rho
at a time screen or go through
configure changes.  This was
provided by activities where you
and there's this whole other
creation process involved in
terms of yes I want to create
the dialogue with this ID, we
would persist that ID and try to
build everything up from scratch
and that ended up being one-off
and kind of awkward to work with
with.  The final goal that was
probably the most obvious in
terms of how we pitched the API
when it was first released is
this idea of decomposing these
master detail UI's.  So if you
have two screens that on a phone
might look something like this
where you have a list of
conversations as well as the
actual conversation itself as
you drill down by tapping into
it, use the back button to get
back to where you were before,
in another configuration you
could take what's essentially
the same code and have it look
like this, so this is something
that you might be freshman with
familiar with
from a lot of UI's that you've
seen.  Isn't then we've kept
building on it.  So we had view
pager and the fragment pager
adapter which a lot of people
still kind of think is the way
to use a view pager just because
for dealing with just bare views
views.  So we've got loaders,
which allow you to do similar
things of persisting some sort
of a request across
configuration changes, keep it
going, whether or not the life
cycle might otherwise interrupt.
medium about this that you
should all read if you haven't
as well.  We also had this idea
of child fragment.  If you can
Nest one legal deep in terms of
putting fragments inside an
activity, why can't you put
fragments inside a fragment that
support in terms a lot of
developers were requesting this
both within Google and external
developers as well and it got
added I think sometime around
the Jelly bean time frame
.  So
how did it work out?  I mean,
some of you kind of already know
the answer to this question, but
these are sort of what we took
as stewards of the pa I, as some
the first problem is that
fragments are so general that
they become really difficult to
explain to people.  So is it
just a pain of the UI, like in
the Gmail example?  Is it
something like dialogue
fragments and something meant to
is it something different
altogether like you can still
have headless fragments that can
act completely independently of
anything else?  We didn't give a
of how to use these things
because we kind of felt like we
didn't want to be too
prescriptive about it and that
ended up really hurting us.  So
of course the idea of even more
life cycle to manage was really
kind of the killer here and the
bugs really didn't help.  This
is really what killed a lot of
people.  Whenever I've talked to
developers about what they would
change about the fragment API or
what problems they have in using
the fragment API, a lot of times
what happens is that you build
up a fragment transaction, you
commit it, and then something
works completely differently
from how you expect.  It's not
particularly intuitive, some of
these things, and it might kind
of remove the entire point of a
bunch of code that you just
spent a lot of time writing.  So
caused a lot of misconceptions.
I mean, fragments, they're just
kind of like views, right?  You
can stick this fragment tags in
one of your layout files,
inflate it, and you are get a
fragment for free.  In hindsight
hindsight, the fragment tag was
this great piece of syntactic
sugar that really confused
people more than it helped in
terms of general education.  So
this immediately made people
think that fragment equals view
and that this is on the same
level of abstraction.  So if we
kind of know where things went
off the rails, then, you know,
how might we start trying to use
effectively?
Well, the first
thing to keep in mind here is
that fragments are roughly
equivalent to an activity in
terms of the level of
abstraction that they act on.
They're come poseable entry
points, and their life cycle and
their surroundings.  They option
optionally manage a UI exprengs
they're really kind of --
presentation and they're really
kind of the whatever and model
view whatever in terms of the
architectural patterns you may
be using within your application
application.  They're not views
themselves, and they're really
not meant to be.  Seriously,
they're not just fancy view
groups.  Fragments implement UI
UI's just by using views, they
compose views, they wire things
up to views in order to do
something more interesting, and
this really kind of comes down
to a core idea that isn't
communicated
communicateed all that widely
that we kind of keep this idea
of an abstraction hierarchy
across the different packages
and the framework.  The higher
level packages are things like
Android.app whereas the views
and widgets are further down the
practice in terms of the
organization of code within the
Android framework is that
anything at a higher level can
import anything from a lower
level but not the other way
around, and if you go looking
through AOSP, you'll probably
find a couple places where we
messed this up, and yes, we know
know, we're sorry.  But overall,
it's managed to be a pretty good
way of organizing some of this
stuff and making sure that
things keep a level of
responsibility that's kind of
appropriate for that type of
component.  So an example of
this is that you might have a
fragment that depends on a view
on click listener in order to
implement that interface.  This
is an example of a fragment
applying policy to a series of
views that it's using.
So while
fragments can depend on views
and implement the interfaces
exposed by those views, it's
important to remember that the
views have no knowledge of
fragments, that fragments really
kind of sit as the policy layer
above whatever UI that you've
built visually and out of the
structure that is used to
generate input events, so on and
so forth.  So really they're
kind of a glue component in this
components or even of other
components within your app.
They allow you to wire up the
view event, the input eefnghts
that you may be generateing from
those views and tell them
something interesting to do, and
life cycle.  What's going on
outside the app?  What's going
on outside the context of that
particular fragment or activity?
fragment when just a composite
custom view group or even just a
include tag will do the job
better.  A lot of people use
this as a point where they can
pivot, where they can decide
what type of UI to show based on
other conditions and between the
rorgs system and custom view
groups, you can solve that
problem without getting into
life cycle constructs.  The real
talking about using a custom
view group or a fragment in
these cases is does it implement
mechanism or does Tim pli meant
policy?  Is it an isolateed
widget that generated its own
input events?  These might be
really complex as well.  We've
got some things in more recent
versions of the support library
like coordinator layout that are
behaviors on their child views,
things that you can push and
pull and move around, stwiep
dismiss, so -- swipe to dismiss,
essentially the user acting on
the UI.  You might be able to
swipe a snack bar apply, hit an
ply button a snack bar and
coordinator layout or grks but
what that actually means it the
application is policy imposeed
by
some other component, and that's
more where fragments sit in the
layering.  So we also can't talk
complexity without talking about
safe state.  So the navigational
state of your application is
partially composed by the
fragments that are currently
attached to it.  These may have
changed over time, con tengts
may have shifted during flight,
so on and so forth wrrks if you
have something like master
detail UI's, then you might have
a very different fragment that
usual showing, if you were
drilled into item A versus
drilled into item B in that list
list, and that's something that
ideally you don't want to have
to track yourself in terms of
other state as it gets restored
as your process dies, you come
back into it, so on and so forth
forth.  So that neens setup of
fragments is conditional and
this is another one of those
kind of weird things tharve sees
with fragments.  Well, why am I
doing this extra check here when
state?  That's partially because
the fragments are going to be re
restored as part of that on
create call.  Now, this has
historically gotten a little bit
with child frag mengts, when
that -- fragments, when that re
reinflation happens really
wasn't consistent with the way
that fragments happen when
attached to activities.  Now,
over the last several months,
we've really kind of dived into
the fragment API's and tried to
Klein a lot of these cases where
are the things that really made
people hate the API to start
with.  As of Android N and
support library version 24,
which is available as part of
the preview STK right now, child
activity attached fragments,
they're consistently reinflateed
know those frag menltses that
were restored from snanlt state
are -- end state are attached to
your activity.  You won't end up
with duplicates when you try to.
(applause).
Deal with that case.  Thank you.
So that alone makes things a
whole lot easier to deal with it
it.
The illegal state exception
exception?  Which one?  We'll
get to it in a minute.
(laughter).
Okay.  So again, we keep coming
back to this idea of fragment
states and that giant diagram of
the so how do we just stop
worrying and love the life cycle
these stages of the life cycle
really does represent a
significant event that can
happen to your application, and
just because we have a lot of
them there doesn't necessarily
mean that you have to care about
all of them all the time.  A lot
of fragments that you write will
only implement a couple of these
methods, but just having all the
options there can really be
overwhelming when you're just
looking at documentation.  So,
you know, that big flow chart
accident like I couldn't tell
you everything on that big flow
chart at once off the top of my
head either, but the nice part
about this is that you really
don't have to hold all of that
in your head at once because
even though those interactions
look very complex, really the
fragment life cycle is driven by
integer value, so this is
straight out of the frag
fragment
source code where we have these
six states that fragments move
between, and the nice thing
about these states is that this
isn't like a completely connect
connected graph of states.  This
is linear.  So when fragments
move from one state to another,
they move through all of the
other states in turn, dispatch
dispatching the appropriate
methods to the fragment to deal
with those life cycle events.
This leads to something really
kind of convenient, which is
that all you need to think about
can think your thinking very
much constrained to each one of
these individual life cycle
methods so that you don't have
to worry about the state of the
entire application in aggregate
when you're dealing with this.
More importantly, you can say
what minimum state will this
component be in or what can I
count on?  Since again, the
fragment states are linear, so
if you know that you're up all
the way at the resumed state,
you know that you've been
through all the other methods,
and this is one of those things
that kind of seems obvious in
hindsight, but again, as you're
looking through the smorgasbord
of methods that you can override
on fragment itself, sometimes
this kind of gets lost in the
noise.  So let's go ahead and
talk about a few other things.
We talked about one bug fix that
was pretty significant, which is
that the child fragment manager
state is guaranteed after the
super dot on create call.  Now,
this is subtlely different from
what I said earlier about re
restoring fragments from instant
really kind of fun bug that
happens, so how many of you use
execute pending transactions for
some part of your work with
fragments or have tried in the
past?  Okay.  Keep your hand up
if you ended up regretting doing
later.  Okay.  Yeah, that's a
pretty close match for some of
that.  So execute pending
transactions is this really
handy method on the fragment
manager that tells it, okay, all
transaction.commit, do all of
them right now, all of them that
got a couple of kind of
interesting issues with it that
we'll get into in a minute, but
one of the interesting things
about that is that you have
expectations after that call.
Specifically, if you've
committed one or more fragment
transactions before that, then
you expect those fragments that
you've committed in that
transaction to be brought up to
a particular state in the life
cycle, usually matching the
container.  Well, it turns out
that that wasn't actually how
things worked.  Some of you
probably found this out, and
this again came down to this
idea of what happens with child
fragments.  You're probably
noticing a bit of a theme here.
that the child fragment manager
itself wouldn't be brought up to
the parents on create returned,
so all of these invariants that
should make it a lot more easy
to reason about your program,
especially when you're saying
that, hey, resolve everything
right now, execute pending
transactions, all that just kind
maid
made things a lot more difficult
difficult.  That's now fixed.
So again you know that you don't
the call on super.create.
Executeing transactions had
another kind of problem as well,
which was that it makes
everything happen right now, and
different parts of your program
might be committing fragment
transactions at different times,
so as soon as you say execute
pending transaction in one piece
piece, you may have just caused
a side effect that affects some
other library that you imported
that uses fragments and you
didn't even know about it.  So
we went ahead and added a commit
transaction which basically does
the same thing but really kind
of what you wanted instead,
which is just this transaction,
commit this one right now.  This
limitation, which is that you
can't deal with fragments on the
now, just because if you have
other fragment transactions
pending, you don't kind of want
to create inversion inside your
back stack in terms of when
those really apply.  We also
added a fragment on attach
fragment method to match the
fragment activity and activity
on attach fragment method.  This
to go ahead and configure a
fragment as it's being attached
to its parent, if you want to do
any sort of injection of
dependencies or, if you want to
do any sort of wiring up much
listeners within that local
activity for other events that
it might publish, this is a
pretty good time to do it except
there really wasn't a good place
to do this with schield
fragments before. -- with child
fragments before.  This was
something that was entirely
skipped.  You couldn't even do
it in the parent activity if you
called on in the parent activity
if and only if the fragment was
attached directly to the
activity, not any of the
children.  So a few other notes
that are kind of useful here.
This is one that some developers
fixed some other bugs around
fragment transitions, which is
that to obtain the state of a
fragment transition, we have to
interrogate the fragment, we
have to call a method on the
fragment to get the transition
values and what it should do,
but in order to make that make
sense to that fragment, we have
to bring the fragment up to the
created state before we ask it
about the transition.  So what
that means, in effect, is that
we have to bring some fragments
up to the createed state before
they become fully attached or
before they replace whatever
fragment that they were
replacing before.  So this is
one of those things that's good
to be aware of.  Don't assume
that just because your fragment
goes through the attach and
create steps that all of the
other surrounding state about a
fragment transaction has
necessarily happened yet.  Again
Again, this is something that
you want to make sure that you
keep your thinking within a
fragment implementation scoped
just to that fragment.  Make
sure that's not trying to take
on responsibilities outside of
itself.  And again, they really
work best when they can behave
as isolated from their
surroundings.  One of the things
aI see people do a lot is that
when a fragment becomes attached
attached, and again, just
because you have problems with
state restoration of more
complex objects, it's pretty
common for people to say okay,
when people get attached to my
fifth, I'm going to go ahead --
attached to my activity, I'm
going to go ahead, grab the
activity and go phishing, see if
fragments by tag, grab any other
sort of associated information
from that activity, downcast it
to a specific type, so on and so
forth.  While this ends up being
pretty convenient, it also means
that those fragments suddenly
become a whole lot less reusable
outset, it is one of those
things that tends to come back
and bite people later on, then
they wonder why didn't we have
some other facility to do this,
to do a cleaner injection of the
forth
forth?  So that was a lot of
information really fast.  Some
of it probably didn't answer a
lot of the core questions that
you may have had coming in here,
don't like this API that I've
used, like change my mind, why
should I go back and give it
another chance?  Really the core
getting any smaller.  So when
you start working especially
across large teams and across
code bases that have lasted for
a very long time, architectural
patterns don't end up being
universal, and this is part of
what Diane was trying to get
into in her post over the week
as well.  If you have a very
long-lived code base, then what
was popular and the obvious way
that everyone should build their
apps back when the code base was
started isn't necessarily true
when you're maintaining it years
to that is to try to create
standard, smarter components.
So how many of you have taken a
look at integration steps for
some library for Android and you
see something that looks kind of
like what's on the slide here?
Okay, go ahead and add this
snipt to your own create, this
thing to your own start, this to
libraries from Google have this
as well, things you need to call
cycle.  That make these types of
integrations really kind of
messy.  Soin stead of that, well
well, we could just have add
this fragment instead and we'll
go ahead and take care of those
extra life cycle steps.  That
suddenly makes that a lot more
reusable and a lot less error-
error-prone.  The nice thing
about this is really that, oh,
or even brert better, you can
just use
one of these tags.  Even though
we had issues around kind of
general education around
fragments on what they could do,
to say here is a piece of my UI,
I just want to drop this
completely self-contained
component here and then not
think about it, to be able to
just configure it possibly from
other XML attributes as
specified there and then just
let that component do its thing.
try and provide these single
points of high-level integration
last part is really key.  Again,
not everyone is going to be
using the same architectural
patterns that your app does and
your own app may not use those
patterns the same wale over time
either, but fragments are kind
of uniquely positioned here, and
closely mirror that activity
life cycle.  There are a few
differences here and there, but
by and large, like as you're
thinking about invariance to
enforce within a fragment, they
really match what you do with
activities as part of that core
entry point idea for Android
components.  So that means that
essentially they can sit below
that level abstraction of your
higher level architecture that
you impose upon your application
component in the same way that
views are reusable to fragments.
communicateing with the rest of
the world, you really need to be
configuration dependent siz that
you I understand up creating
dpaish dependencyies that you
end
up creating.  Again, this comes
down to that issue of are you
going phishing in your parent
activity or in your parent
fragment for other dependencies
and is that fragment going on
blow up in those things aren't
there?  Are those dependencies
documented?  How is someone use
that go fragment necessarily
going to know that's a
requirement?  In a code base
within a particular team, again,
as things grow over time, we
tend to see a lot of these
patterns show up.  That means
that you really do need to
consider your audience as you're
building these things.  If
you're building Lyle bone marrow
building libraryies, the answer
is going to be a lot different
than if just building a screen
in your own application.  Your
own application, sure, go ahead
and take a dependency on some
internal component.  It might
help, but at the very least
you're not passing this out to
the rest of the wider world.
Also if you are offering the
ability to use fragments that
are these standalone drop-in
components, the uninflate method
these, so this lets you do the
same thing that you do with
views:  Specify some
configuration attributes.  It
might be something like an API
key, it might be something like
any other sort of information
that you need to pass to that
fragment as arguments but you
can do it without having to muck
necessarily during that initial
start-up phase of your
application, because again, you
want to try to have one
integration point with these
things.  All right.  So this
talk wouldn't be complete if I
didn't open myself up to the mic
answers.  So come on up.  Sure.
>> Hi. Two questions. First of
commit now, other stuff.
>> ADAM POWELL: Yes, those are
coming into version 24 of the
support library, you can use
that now in developer cr preview
3.  The unattach fragments for
parent fragments didn't make the
3-RBGS but that will be in the
next.
>> What about the fragments,
like if you're looking in the
source code, you find the show
is using the old commit.
>> ADAM POWELL: Dialogue
fragment.  Yes.  There are a
bunch of exoanltses in the core
parts -- there are a bunch of
components in the core parts.
Dialogue fragments, also the
fragment page dapter was another
one of these things used to
execute pending transactions and
about that.  Those have been up
updated to use commit now where
it makes sense already.
>> Do you have any
recommendations on handling
illegal state exceptions?
(laughter)
.
>> ADAM POWELL: Any
recommendations on illegal state
exceptions.  I assume what you
mean is the wurch that comes up
when state -- the one that comes
up when state has already been
saved for the activity.  Is that
>> Yeah.
>> ADAM POWELL: Okay. This is
really case by case and it's
part of the reason why we have
this idea of commit versus
commit allowing a state loss.
It's kind of up to your app in
some of these cases, and
sometimes you can tolerate the
state loss of if a fragment
transaction didn't happen,
sometimes you really don't want
that to happen.  The biggest
issue where it tends to come up
is when you're responding to a
button click or some other sort
of asynchronous event.  It might
happen as a result of a network
request, so on and so forth.  A
lot of those you're just going
to have to make the call of how
valid it is to kind of drop that
on the floor in the worst case
scenario where your process dies
case by case.  If it's general
navigation state, I would say
that commit allowing state loss
isn't a huge deal.  The user
will be a little confused as
they come back and they're at a
previous screen from maybe what
they expected, but again, you
can use some other mechanisms in
there as well, like since the
fragments are going to know
about the listeners that they've
attached to those buttons and
sort of what to deal with or
your activity will know about
that, then you can gauge that on
stop state for that component,
so forth, that's one way to deal
listeners entirely when you
become stopped, but overall it
really kind of depends on what
it's doing.  If you're able to
let the state drop on the floor,
then committing state loss can
be just fine.
>> This one is kind of a little
more specific.  With certain
libraries that have used kind of
fragments to encapsulate a bunch
of action, more specifically
like Android Pay.  Do you have
any advice with using those for
things like recyclers where it's
get something basically the
Android Pay button is the best
example I have right now, just
kind of to live in that life
cycle or anything like that or
any advice for that or any best
practices we can look up?
>> ADAM POWELL: Definitely stay
something we're looking into
pretty closely, the question
specifically being around adding
fragments to recycling
containers like a recycling view
view.  List view will probably
be a little more difficult but
it's definitely been on our mind
through the development of re
recycler view that this is
something we're going to want to
do.  So I think that it's still
like some developers have kind
of dove into it and they've
fowrched some effective -- found
can definitely do it the way
that view pager does in the
pager adapters, if you're really
careful about when those things
get committed.  Recycler view
and others have some pretty
strict requirements over
basically just like when some of
these things need to happen,
like they need to know that this
view holder, so on and so forth.
I think that we need to put out
some better documentation on
that at the very least and it
may come along with a few other
API changes to recycler view.
>> Sounds great. Thank you.
>> My question touches upon the
commit allowing state loss.  So
if you have a scenario where you
have one fragment and that's
talking to the server, then the
user backgrounds the app, the
response comes back from the
server and that fragment needs
to transition to some other
fragment.  At that point if we
use commit allowing state loss,
what are the recommendations for
doing that?  Is it okay to use
it?  Is it not okay?
>> ADAM POWELL: What you might
want to think about, and I'm
going to go ahead and plug in on
loaders on this one is that a
lot of these requests that are a
async, you can use a loader to
encapsulate that request.  Not
only will that give you
stability across other configure
deal with the load finished
operation.  Basically you can
make sure that you will defer
dealing with that until you've
become started again if the
fragment has already become
stopped.  So I would say that's
probably the most automated way
of dealing with that sort of
thing, but you can re-create a
similar mechanism without
loaders as well.
>> I see. So if there is no
state to be saved, I mean, I'm
okay, I don't have any data to
save in that state, then I'm
okay with committing
state loss,
right?
>> ADAM POWELL: Definitely. If
the data you're representing
doesn't represent a conditional,
drops on the floor, it's okay
for the user.
>> Thank you.
>> One of the very difficult
problems that I have is whenever
you want topped a fragment
transaction, -- to do a fragment
that?  Because then you'll deal
with the state exception for
sure.
>> ADAM POWELL: Yes, because
that ends up happening a little
bit too early.
>> Or are you looking at better
aligning the activity methods
with the life cycle methods?
>> ADAM POWELL: We did a bunch
of work on that.  The activity
result issue in particular
around committing new fragment
transactions I don't think we
got to.  Let me take a note on
that and get a better answer for
>> Okay on, cool. Thanks.
>> ADAM POWELL: You're welcome.
>> I'm a little bit confused
about implementing master
details now, when you said
fragments should be isolateed.
I
can't isolate the detail section
master fragment, so that's one
question.  The other question is
is, when you look at a more
complicated master detail like
five system navigation where you
have a full blown tree, how does
that work?  So what do you think
I should avoid or how to fix my
app in general?
>> ADAM POWELL: I would say try
to keep a fairly tree-shaped
model of ownership in terms of
those components and make sure
that you have a single owner for
item is this concept that is
relevant to both the master and
detail views, then perhaps
that's a piece of state that
belongs in a parent to both of
those instead and that way that
parent is able to to go ahead
and configure both of those
fragments and provide that imlu
and wireup in the same way that
happens with other forms of nest
nesting.
>> But then I'll have to do the
phishing you talked about from
the fragment up.
>> ADAM POWELL: Not necessarily
necessarily.  If you set either
the listeners or some other
similar construct, do dependency
injection, anything like that
from the parent to the fragments
fragments, then the fragments
themselves will already have
those resources when they need
to have them available and
they'll go ahead and get events
when those changes occur.
>> So your advice is inversion
of control?
>> ADAM POWELL: A little bit,
yes.
>> Awesome. Thanks.
>> Hi. Could you explain a
little more what you meant about
the difference between policy
and mechanism?
>> ADAM POWELL: Sure. I mean,
I guess in like Git terms, it's
a little bit like the porcelain
versus the plumbing.  It's the
idea of what are you seeing at
the top level at the interaction
versus what are the elements
that are being composeed to
create those interactions.  So
for example, a button would be
just pure mechanism.  A button
clicks, a button can be focused,
it, so forth, but it doesn't
really do anything in the
context of your app oits own.
You have on its own.
You have to attach a listener
and populate it with text, so
forth.  It's that that's really
acting in that same role that I
meant in terms policy in that
case.
>> Another question sort of
related to illegal state loss.
The answer may be the same to
look at in like post end loaders
loaders, but one specific
instance that we have, we've
encountered a number of times is
showing a progress dialogue and
a dialogue fragment and since
it's saved in the state, it
handles it across rotation,
which is great, but then if the
user backgrounds the app, then
it finishes attempting to
dismiss that dialogue
doesn't
work because we can do a commit
allowing state loss but it
wouldn't dismiss it because un
unsaved state has already
occurred.  What would your
recommendation be for dealing
with that situation.
>> ADAM POWELL: I'm trying to
understand a little better.  You
representing some operation in
flight.  First off, progress
dialogues are evil and from a UX
perspective, but the same sort
of thing shows up if you're
showing like a progress spinning
line or something like that to
begin with.  So you've got this
operation in flight and you want
to swap that out for the real
content afterwards, is that
correct?
>> Yeah, basically
uninterruptible action, so to
speak, and then at some point
after that action is done, the
progress dialogue goes away and
then something happens, but the
goal, our goal would be to avoid
there when the user comes back
to the app even though the
action has already finished
.
>> ADAM POWELL: So you want to
have it go away entirely,
regardless.  So that when you
bring the other window back to
the front, then you're not
seeing the progress dialogue for
that split second as you're
dismissing it, or is it just
kind of the issue of what to do
when you end up in that
inconsistent state?
>> Yes. Since it was dismissed,
post saved instant state, that
it would be there still when you
restoration.
>> Best way I've seen for
dealing with that
is that you
have the operation in flight and
flight when saved instance state
occurs, you want to record that
that operation was still in
flight somehow, then when you
come back on the other side or
even just when you receive on
start again, when you become
visible again, then you can
perform the other cleanup at
that point rather than doing it
immediately there.  As I was
aloud
alluding to to start with, it
might provide a little bit of a
visual jink there because you
might come back later and you
see that progress dialogue for a
disappears, so you could
probably work with some kind of
hybrid solution there just to
get rid of that visual jink, do
the committing state losses but
still record that operation was
still in flight and wire that up
on the other side.  This is the
sort of thing that loaders are
really good at.
>> Thank you.
>> ADAM POWELL: Sure.
>> Can you explain more about un
uninflate?  You said one uses
more of them.
>> ADAM POWELL: I'm sorry. I
skimmed over that a little
quickly.  So fragments have an
on inflate method that receives
the attribute set that was used
to inflate during the layout
inflation process, so just as
when you're inflateing a custom
view, you get that attribute set
and you can read out a bunch of
configure values and apply them.
just specified in layout XML and
apply those to the fragments
arguments bundle or so forth.
>> Oh, to pass information to
the fragment basically?
>> ADAM POWELL: Yeah, and it's
mostly configuration information
place like that.
>> Thank you.
>> Dprag meant apps I have a
question.  So one of the things
that I see missing is a simple
like on fragment visible user
and on fragment hidden from user
user.  That's a very common
scenario where you want to like
fetch some fresh data for the
user to see?
>> ADAM POWELL: This is
entirely a failure of our
documentation because this is
there.  Fragments have a method
method --
>> Okay. I know of the set use
usability method but there's no
life cycle method associated
with that so you have to kind of
>> ADAM POWELL: What we did for
that so far, you're right, it's
not part of the life cycle in
that case, again, this kind of
ties into the loader idea, is
that if the visible fragment, if
you have invisible fragments but
a visible fragment has loaders
associated with it, then we'll
defer the start phase of the
other fragments that rnlt are
not
user visible until the loaders
in other start phase has
completely occurred for the
visible fragment so we can
prioritize a lot of those things
things, but it sounds like
you're probably asking for
something a little more detailed
than that, like probably a phase
where you can start and stop
animations or something similar.
>> Simple thing would be like
I'm looking at my fantasy roster
standings and I want to look at
the lateest lateest settings or
something
to my matchups and want to see
the latest match-up score
because there's a game happening
happening.  That's where you
want to fetch some fresh data
when the user comes to that page
page?
>> ADAM POWELL: I see. In that
case you want something that's
akin to that aim sort same sort
of
transition edge call Belle
back.
>> Yeah.
>> ADAM POWELL: That's a good
idea.  We'll take a look at it.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi. What do you think of
activity on the module fragments
while building an app?  Is this
good or not?  And do you
recommend this pattern?
>> ADAM POWELL: Okay. So
you're saying just one activity
with multiple fragments?
>> Yeah.
>> ADAM POWELL: Kind of the
equivalent of like a single page
web app in a lot of ways.
>> Yeah.
>> ADAM POWELL: I would say it
has the same merits as single
page apps on the web.  In the
sphorm of that activity acting
as a container for those
fragments, then by all means,
yeah, that can totally work.
What you're trading off, though,
points for your application.  So
for example, if you have the
ability to deep link into some
parts of your am caig from like
another of your application from
would open that one activity in
line, then that case will get
more complicated because you'll
want to have that entry point
for deep linking into your
application with a specific
detail view that might be ash
temporarily far down -- ash
temporarily far down -- tash
arbitrary.  You can have a
container using only for those
deep links and stick normal
detail fragments for viewing
that content into that one
container, but then you have to
deal with this idea of what task
it lives in the context of the
calling task, then things are
pretty easy, you hit back,
activity finishes, user goes on
their way.  In most cases I
would say that's probably the
way to go when dealing with
those types of interactions, but
trade-offs in terms of other
entry points using a few more
activities can sometimes make
things a little bit easier to
reason about in terms of those
because you don't have as many
duplicated code paths.
>> Thank you.
>> ADAM POWELL: Do we have time
for one more?  No.  Okay.  Meet
right outside, and I would be
glad to take your question.
Thank you all for coming.
(The session concluded at
5:46
5:46 p.m.
)
May 18, 2016.
>>
LM1.
Location and Proximity
Super
Superpours
superarepoweraresuperSuper
Superpowers,
he had store
powers, Eddystore and
Google.
.
>> PETER LEWIS: All right.
Hello.  Hello, everybody, and
welcome.  My name is Peter, and
I am the product manager for
Eddystone and the Google Beacon
platform, and I am uncomfortable
ly
excited today to be talking to
you about location and proximity
Superpowers.  So we'll cover a
whole bunch of stuff, and it's
going to be awesome.  So if my
clicker works.  Oh, that was the
get into some code, but before
we do that, I want to introduce
you to my dog.  This is Oscar.
Oscar is like my sidekick, I
suppose, if we're talking about
Superpowers.  He is a four
four-year-old Papion and one of
my favorite things is taking him
near where I live and taking him
for a long walk amongst all the
trees and the bushes, and while
I'm walking along are he's
constantly sniffing, discovering
is this an important bush?  Is
this a stick I should be playing
of all of the important places
and objects that are around him
and this session is about to
make your users' devices almost
as awesome as Oscar.
(laughter).
So today I want to talk to you
a bit about a few sort of
location-based experiences.
Here are a few examples from
within Google apps.  In the
photos app I can search for
photos I took when I was at
Google in New York, there's
timeline for helping users to re
rediscover places that they've
been to and experiences they've
had out there, and then there's
sort of popular times for one of
London that reminds me it's been
two months, I should probably go
again.  And these kind of
location-based experiences make
apps really compelling.  If you
can provide services to your
users that take accounted of the
important places -- take account
of the important places and
objects to them, then you can
build engagements and be much
more successful.  So all of
these are powder by a
complicated array of sense he is
experience at the end of it is
really simple.  They use WiFi,
cell tower location, GPS to
produce this kind of thing.  But
to develop your own apps and
even in cases where you don't
have an app on top of this
platform of the so today we will
the open beacon format from
Google, and we want to make it
so that the beacons you have on
your desk actually become useful
beacons with the Cloud so that
you can think of them much more
like Cloud objects.  That, we're
going to talk about attachments,
subscriptions and nearby and
sharing those beacons with
others so that this physical
widget gets all of the power of
the Cloud.  Then last up, we're
going to talk about something
new that was announced an hour
ago in stage 1 I think, powering
through Google.  So even in the
case where you don't have your
app installed, how can you use
beacons to bring awesome
experiences to your users?  So
what is the technology we're
going to use?  Well, we're going
to use beacons, and in fact,
beacons are not new at all, if I
Beacons are not new.  So here is
an example of a beacon, a
lighthouse, and all of the
components of the Google beacon
platform are similar to a
lighthouse and a ship at sea.
So you have the lighthouse
itself.  That's the Eddystone
beacon.  It just sits there and
it broadcasts an identifier to
the world.  Meanwhile, out at
sea, the captain of the ship has
got their telescope.  They're
looking out for all of the
beacons that are around the
coastlines of countries.  That's
and the Cocopod for iOS.  But
just sighting the beacon is not
that useful.  You'll also need a
chart with all of the beacons
mapped out on it to look at
exactly where you are and that
chart is provided by the
proximity beacon API which is
the Cloud service you can use to
So we'll go through each of
those parts but with the Google
beacon platform rather than
lighthouses and ships, and by
the end this session, you'll be
able to build awesome beacon
powered experiences in your app
and also we're going on give you
beacons in the cases where your
app is not yet on the user's
device.  So what is a BLE beacon
beacon?  Well, I have one just
here.  They're sort of simple
typically battery-powered
devices that you can use to mark
important places and objects in
the world.  You stick them on
the object, and they just
broadcast an identifier.  They
do exactly one thing.  The
identifier that they broadcast
is only 31 bytes long and by the
time you've got rid of all the
headers, there's not really much
placing an abstract identifier
in your beacon that you mark,
you make deviceers that come
near
it aware of that place.  Because
beacons only accept connections
from devices when they're being
configured, they're really good
for deploying in public places.
Bluetooth things all the time.
You just want your user's device
important places and objects
around it so beacons have been
around for a little while and
Bluetooth beacons have as well,
and in the olden days, we sort
of had this model that you would
to a particular app, and it
would probably power a
particular feature in that app.
We're taking a slightly
different approach with
Eddystone and the Google beacon
platform.  We're interested in
having one beacon or many
beacons with many uses.  So you
deploy your infrastructure once
and then you can reuse it
multiple times in different apps
from different people all coming
to your venue.  So what is step
1?  Well, we've provided an app
for you to get started.  It's
called beacon Teelz available on
, available
on the Play Store, download this
to beacons, it's an app that
allows you to register beacons
with the Google Cloud Platform.
So it sits between the beacon
and proximity beacon API.  You
can register beacons that have a
number of different frame types.
This is the complete Eddystone
specification.  There are four
frame types in Eddystone.
There's Eddystone UID, which is
the abstract market for a
particular place.  For cases
where you're interested in
controlling who has access to
your beacon signal, there's
Eddystone EID, and I'll talk
about that a bit in a minimum
nut.  The third frame stiep a
telemetry frame.  This reports
on the beacon's battery level,
which makes it easy to monitor a
fleet of beacons once they're
deployed in the wild.  Then
finally you can put a pretty
tiny URL into the beacon frame
itself and Eddystone URL
formingz the backbone of the
physical web. -- forms the
backbone of the physical web cht
Eddystone EID and you can see
I've made a beacon with a pretty
What that represents is that the
beacon frame itself is
continuously changing.  Soif a
beacon, it's broadcasting one
frame, then a few nints later
it's broadcasting a different
frame.  Your beacon general
ratings those frames based upon
a cryptographic key that's
stored within the beacon itself.
That key is also shared with
another service, which is able
to resolve a siting of that
particular beacon to a stable ID
in your app.  It's particularly
goold for cases where you want
to control who has access to the
beacon signal that you're
deploying.  The good news is
that all of our API's support UI
UID and EID transparently, so
you don't have to bother
thinking about the EID.  You can
them both through the same
nearby API and Android.  So
that's Eddystone.  We've got
static identifiers, which are
are in
a sense the simplest way to get
started, and we've got ephemeral
identifiers, these are the ones
that are ideal for controlling
your beacon signal.  That's just
the beacon itself.  The real
power comes from the Cloud
service that you associate,
where you put that beacon.  And
that is fronted by proximity
beacon API.  Proximity beacon AP
API fronts Google's beacon
registry that allows you to
register beacons, associate
information with them, and add
attachments which can be used by
your own app.  So a beacon
object looks a bit like this.
I've represented it as a box.
Within the box we've got three
attachments represented by these
three colors.  So let's have a
look at the beacon registry
entry itself.  Here is the list
of properties that you can
associate with a beacon.  First
up you can assign the beacon a
description.  The description of
the beacon is your human
readable name for that
particular beacon, and we'll
talk a bit about how you can
search for things like that
later.  You can add properties
to a beacon, so it's sometimes
useful to remember the transmit
power that you associateed with
a
particular beacon or some other
properties that are relevant to
your particular venue.  Then the
next set of objects is to do
with place and location.  When
you register a beacon with
Google, you can associate a
place ID with it which goes into
the heart of Google's location
infrastructure.  So all of the
outer place functionality that I
showed earlier just gets better
when you have a beacon signal
registered with a place ID.  As
well as that, beacons enable new
in particular, you can associate
within indoor level with a
beacon, which makes it much
easier for your app to detect
which level a user is on in a
building.  This last field,
expected stability, allows you
to distinguish between beacons
that you deploy in a static
place, sort of marking important
places in a building, and those
perhaps that are on a bus or a
food truck or poo move around.
Finally we have the ephemeral ID
support Eddystone EID.  So if
you're using Eddystone EID bee
corngz you'll need to
beacons, you'll need to talk to
this part of the API.  Finally,
when you provision a beacon
using the Eddystone gap service,
there is a key you can use to
unlock that particular hardware
and we can store that for you to
make beacon administration
easier later on.  So what's next
next?  We have a beacon, we have
a Cloud service.  On a user's
device in the middle we have the
you on a sort of brief tour of
the nearby API showing how you
can use it to fetch attachments
back to your beacon, back to
your user's device.  So this is
what you need to put in your
manifest.  It's important that
you put your API key to talk to
the nearby mess saj's API.  You
also need a service running in
the background if you want
background beacon scanning, and
you can also put intent filters
in your manifest as well.
That's something you should do
because of a reason I'm going to
you've connected to the API,
once you've connected to Google
Play services and your Android
activity, then this is the meat
of your sub subscription.  So
this
is where you tell the nearby API
that I'm interested in
attachments for particular name
space and a particular type.
It's that line on the set filter
filter.  So what happens next?
Well, the nearby API takes all
of the information that you've
given it and it does beacon
scanning for you.  Notice that
you don't have to care about the
broadcasting.  You've created a
subscription to a Cloud object,
nearby it's going on hide all
the sophistication in the
background.  So nearby goes out
looking for beacons and when it
does beacon scans, it shows them
across all apps that have active
subscriptions, as well as that
when the Android platform does
scans, they're also shared to
nearby, so you get a lot more
scans for a lot less battery use
use.  When nearby comes out and
finds a beacon, it will query
the proximity beacon API to say,
don't know what it means, and
proximity beacon API will return
that you had subscribed tovment
let's take a to.
Let's look at what an attachment
looks like.  They're pretty
simple objects.  They have these
the project.  The name space is
owned by your project, so you
have a name space for your
particular Developer Console
project.  After that you can put
a type for each attachment.
That could be platforms at a
station or it could be different
types of vehicle.  It can be
anything you want.  Then the
second field is the data that
you associate with that beacon
under that name space type.  So
this is where you put the
information that you actually
want to get back in your app
when your user sights that
particular beacon.  If you're
calling the API directly,
remember to base 64 and code it,
for you.  So nearby had the
subscription to a particular
name space and type, proximity
beacon API decided if there were
that had been seen that
correlate with your particular
subscription and then those
attachments are returned to your
morning, if you don't care about
sort of integrateing with API's
and so on, you can use the
beacon dashboard.  This is a web
dashboard that actual uses the
JavaScript client library to
proximity beacon API and allows
you to visualize all of your
beacons and edit the information
associateed with them.  So for a
particular beacon object,
registering a beacon just become
becomes filling in a bunch of
fields on here.  We think this
is really cool.  You can also
add attachments.  Here is an
example an attachment that I
added this morning.  And you can
filling in two fields on a web
dashboard.  You now have a
registered de deacon beacon and
an
attachment associated with it.
So where have we come?  Well, we
provisioned it using Beacon
Tools, which you can get from
the Play Store or the iOS app
store, then we associateed that
beacon in the Cloud with
proximity beacon API which allow
allowed us to create this beacon
object and add attachments to it
it.  If you didn't want to call
the API, we had the dashboard,
and then down in the bottom
right we've got the model of
what happens when a user's
device comes across a beacon,
and as I said earlier, it
doesn't matter whether you're
using Eddystone UID or EID,
nearby will behave exactly the
same.  You just create a
subscription to the name space
and type of attachment that
you're interested in.  So I
mentioned earlier that there are
registering beacons in the Cloud
Cloud, and one of those is that
you can create a beacon network
and share it with many different
recently, proximity beacon API
is one of the first API's to use
access management roles, giving
fine grain location, fine grain
control over which developers
can make use of your beacon
network.  So here we go.  Here
is a picture of the Google Cloud
under identity and access
management you can add members
to your project, so these are
adding developers who can sort
of do things with resources that
are in your project, things like
compute engine instances or data
store and so on.  Proximity
beacon API is one of these.  So
once you've enableed the API,
you
can add a developer and choose
from the roles that we have
available.  So these are the new
roles, and I want to just go
through them a bit and tell you
about what they allow develop
erpz to do with your beacon
network.  So first up is beacon
editor.  If you grant a
developer this role, then
they're able to add beacons to
your project.  It's important if
if, for example, the person who
is writing the app is not the
person who is going and sticking
is going and sticking up the
beacon, you want them to be able
project, but you don't want them
to be able to fiber off compute
engine instances.  So compute
beacon awk sign to a user or a
group to be able to enable them
to add beacons to your project.
It's important to note that
beacon ID's are universally
unique in Google's beacon
registry.  Once a beacon has
been registered, it can't be
registered by a different
project.  Next up we have
attachment editor.  I mentioned
earlier that attachments have
name spaces associated with them
your project.  Attachment editor
allows you to say I want this
developer to be able to add
attachments to my beacons in my
name space.  So that means they
can add attachments that can
interact with your app, and they
beacon editor so they can
register a beacon to your
project and they can add
attachments to it as well
without all of the other
permissions that come as a
result of being an owner of a
project.  Finally is attachment
publisher.  What this allows,
you can say that developer can
create attachments in their own
name space on my beacons.  So I
have a beacon network and I can
say my friend here, I want them
to be able to add attachments in
their own name space that will
talk to their own app on my
beacons.  And these roles and
these new sharing paradigms
allow a bunch of useful things.
So here we have three different
phones belonging to three
different users with three
different active nearby
subscriptions all talking to the
same beacon, and these
attachments can be added by
different developers.  So
there's a lot of flexibility in
the way that you can use a
beacon network.  You don't any
longer just deploy one beacon
for one app.  We have one beacon
(applause).
Yeah, it's awesome.
(applause)
.
Right.  So interacting with
Google products.  Sometimes
people come to me and they say,
Peter, PM for beacons.  This is
fantastic, but my app has to be
everywhere in order for it to be
useful.  This is not true.  So
what I want to talk about now is
and interact with Google
products at the heart of Android
Android, like nearby
notifications.  So nearby
notifications was announced just
an hour ago and is available in
the next version of Google Play
services, but what I want to
tell you today is how you can
register beacons today and add
attachments that will interact
with nearby notifications.  Near
by notifications allows you to
prompt notifications in Android
in three different categories or
cases.  You can associate web UR
URL's with your beacons, so
you've registered a beacon, you
can associate a URL with it.
You can associate app intents.
Sorm earlier I said make sure
that you've put intents in your
Android manifest.  You can point
attachment and if the user
doesn't have your app installed,
full.  So if I have your app
installed, I come near the
beacon, it intends into your app
app.  If I don't have your app
installed, it says here is a
website.  And then last up,
there's direct app installs.  So
this is an early program and
we're holding it behind a white
list at the moment.  So if you
would like to apply to have your
installs associated with beacons
beacons, then you can go to
developers
Google/near dem by/
by/notifications and it will
tell you how to get started.
Let's look at what these look
like.  Here are three examples
of nearby notifications.  Right
up at the Tom, we've got an app
for a coffee shop and this
passioned our white list because
of a particular reason and that
was that a user could take an
action if they haded app they
had they had the app
installed right at that place.
It's very much about is the user
then do something immediately
with it.  That's a really good
candidate for nearby
notifications.  In the second
case this is an example where
it's Kim's Vitamins, a URL, a
web URL was associated with the
beacon that pointed to a
particular website managed by
that business.  And then at the
bottom we've got everybody's
favorite example in San
Francisco apparently, paying for
parking.  Finding an app where
you can pay for parking and
actually use it right then to
pay for the place where you've
just parked is another good
canned datd for nearby
candidate for nearby
notifications.  Let's go back to
look at it.  We have three
attachments on this beacon.  The
you added.  So they're things
that interact with your app.
Maybe you've got some kind of
beacon functionality button.
But we wanted to focus on the
top one just here and what
you'll notice about it is that
the name space for this
particular attachment is not
your project.  This is com.
com.Google.nearby, a name space
reserveed for nearby
notifications.  Any developer
can write attachments in this
name space, but they can only
attach those attachments to
their own beacons.  So if you
register a beacon with Google
shes you can write into this
name space.  If this other
person registers a beacon with
Google, I cannot write into that
you have to own a beacon in
order to take part with nearby
notifications.  So let's have a
look.  We have the nearby
attachment and you can see that
it's in this com.Google.nearby
name space.  In the type field,
we've put en, hyphen, debug.  En
want to show your nearby
notifications to users who have
set the default language on
their device to the notification
in the data we've got some
nearby attachment data.  This is
you would build if you were
putting functionality in your
own app.  So what does this data
look like?  Well, it's just with
a title, a description and a
description.  You can create
this that easy and the URL is
the part that's interesting.  So
carefully.  So here are the
three different categories of
nearby notification that I
mentioned before.  Up at the top
top, this is the URL that we
would associate with a direct
app install, you can see it
points to a particular package
in the noid Play Store.  In the
middle this is a URL that we
would associate with if the user
hazy the app installed, intent
into it, if they don't have the
app installed, then we'll fall
back to a website.  And then at
the bottom, you've got the
simple case, just a web URL.
The go hiech to with that
someone you have -- the go-to
with that one is you have to
remember it's https.  Http URL's
is the end of the content for
this talk.  I'm now going to do
a demo for your entertainment
and amusement that is possibly
the most dangerous demo that's
ever been dofnlt I'm going to
use two different kinds of radio
radio, I'm going to use an un
unreleased product, I'm going to
use a product that we launched
this afternoon, and I'm going on
before your very eyes, here is
my beacon.  It's broadcasting,
and in Beacon Tools I can search
for it just like this.
Excellent.  It's shown up.  So I
register it.  I'm glad that
nobody got there before me.  If
somebody else had registered
that beacon, this would not have
(laughter).
Right.  So what I just did was I
broadcasting at Eddystone UID
and I registered registered it
with my
product.  You can see that I
tested this, what, maybe seven
times before I got in here, and
this is the beacon dashboard
that I was talking about earlier
earlier.  So if I refresh it,
fingers crossed, here is my new
beacon that I just registered
right now.  By the way, if this
all works, I want you guys to
give ale cheer that is loud
enough to wake the engineers in
London who made it.  So I can
associate some information with
my beacon.  So the IO beacon.
This is the human readable label
that I want to associate with
the beacon so I can find it
later.  I can associate a place
with it, so I can put it in
Amphitheater Parkway, and this
will plug into the rest of
Google's location infrastructure
infrastructure, as I mentioned
before.  This particular beacon,
this is not going on move around
around, so I'm going to make it
stable.  Now, here are some sort
of useful administrative labels
for me.  So I can add in things
like, I don't know, the tx power
power, the transmit power of
this particular beacon.  Maybe
it's broadcasting at minus 20 DB
20 DBM.  Great.  So I've now
registered this beacon with
Google, I've added a description
so that I can sort of find it
again, and I put a place ID with
attachments to it.  So here is
the name space that's associate
ed
with my project, and it is very
easy to add an attachment.
There we go.  I just press plus,
registered with an attachment to
it, so I can use nearby mess
stooges get that attachment back
you should go to the code labs
tent and there is a code lab
specifically on nearby
subscriptions from nearby
messages, so make sure you go
there in order to get some of
these attachments back, and
we've created a zoo of
attachments around IO.  So if
you do it on your own phone,
you'll be able to collect all of
those animals.  Finally is this
category, nearby notifications.
this like Jason object that you
can construct but what we decide
than that.  We just have a web
form that you can fill in.  I
can put a title in here, I can
put a description for the
notification that I want to show
show.  Can somebody give me a
random word?
>> Bacon.
>> PETER LEWIS: Bacon. Perfect
Perfect.  The bacon.  This is
going on prove that I am doing
had live -- this says going on
prove that I am doing this live.
I'm going on put it in English
and how -- I'm going to put it
in English and how about we just
point to Google.com.  Great.  So
I can check all of the details I
put and I can create the
attachment like that.  So what
this has done is createed a
nearby notifications attachment
on that beacon that I registered
on the stage live in front of
all of you.  Let's go back to
the device over here, and on
this particular phone I have
nearby notifications running.
So when I screen on and I pull
down the notification shade, and
I screen on again, I am going to
see a couple of websites that
are not the ones that I was
thinking of.  Third time lucky.
It looks like it might not work.
So what's happening is it does a
beacon scan when the screen
comes on.  I'm hoping it can see
right next to it.  There we go.
The bacon.
(cheers and applause).
I select that and Google Chrome
appears.  So we registered the
beacon, we added a nearby
notifications attachment to it,
and that took us straight to
that link when the user's device
beacon platform.  One beacon,
many uses.  I will take some
questions.  Thank you.
(applause)
.
>> Two questions. One, do you
get range information as in how
many meters approximately?
Second, how does this function
offline?  If you've been there
before and you come back and
don't have a connection, will it
>> PETER LEWIS: The answer of
to your second question is as of
services is yes.  The answer to
your second question, as of the
next version of Google Play
services, yes, but.  Using the
receive signal strength of a
beacon to do precise distance is
attempt.  So we've deliberately
taken quite a discreet approach,
beacon or you don't see the
beacon, and that I think allows
them to sort of mark places
precisely.  So yes.  They're not
ilaterat I say on
indoors.
>> Will the beacon recognize
that you had your device
notified before?  If you come in
the same door three times, will
you get that message every time?
>> PETER LEWIS: That's the kind
of functionality that you can
build in your app to sort of
count how many times a user has
seen a particular beacon.  We
just tell you that that beacon
has been seen and then you can
decide what you do with that
information, whether I've seen
it twice before or whatever.
>> How long does the battery
last on one beacon?
>> PETER LEWIS: How long does
the battery last?  That is a
good question.  How long is a
piece of string?  It depends how
big the battery you buy is.
Typically we're now looking at
new-ish beacons that are a
couple of years plus, and
particularly if you're buying
beacons that have several double
>> You mentioned when you
register a beacon with a project
project, it's registered sort of
permanently.  Can you unregister
them to reuse them for
development purposes in other
projects or other people?
>> PETER LEWIS: So you can
currently decommission a beacon,
which sort of gets rid of it for
eternity.  The best strategy is
just to reprovision your beacon
and then register it again.
>> For the ephemeral frames, can
public access to the ephemeral
frame resolution, or does it
have to be one specific?
>> PETER LEWIS: Yes, absolutely
absolutely.  You can register an
EID beacon, you can add an
attachment to t then you can say
publicly visible.  It's probably
ale feature I should have
mentioned during the talk.  So
you can make your name spaces
publicly visible so any
developer can subscribe to it,
and this allows you to create
public beacon networks, which is
exactly what we've done here
here at I/O.  So a developer
that sub subscribes to your name
space will just get the
information you associate with
the beacon.
>> Thank you.
>> My plans for an API for
registering beacons so we can
automate that process?
>> PETER LEWIS: Yes, proximity
API is the proximity for
registering beacons.
>> Does scanning only occur
while you have the screen lit?
Is there no way to get a
notification while the phone is
in your pocket?
>> PETER LEWIS: There is a way
to get notifications when the
phone is in your pocket.  If you
subscription and you can go to
the code lab to find out how to
do that, then you will benefit
from scans that happen when the
screen off.
>> But you have to pull down to
see them or is there a way to
get --
>> PETER LEWIS: To interact
with any notification, the
screen has to be on.  By default
neer by forces a scan when the
screen comes on.  It gets scans
tuneist cli when the screen is
--
opportunist cli when the screen
off, and also you can have a
foreground that says I want to
start scanning now and will tell
>> Is it always a user pull to
see the notification?
>>
>> PETER LEWIS: It's always a
user pull.  If I've interacted
with a particular notification
before, then they appear on my
locked screen.  Yeah.
>> First, is it available just?
Android or also other platforms?
>> PETER LEWIS: Nearby
notifications is part of Google
Play services, so it's on
Android.  Nearby messages, there
is an API for Android also in
Play Services and there is a Coc
Cocopod for iOS.  If you've done
beacon scanning yourself, you
can hit proximity beacon API
directly and say I've found this
ID, tell me about it.
>> Second question, today was
announced about Android and
instant apps.  Are you actually
looking at maybe interact with
that as well?
>> PETER LEWIS: Answer is yes.
>> Awesome. Thank you.
>> Once the beacon is registered
with the proximity API, what
happens when the device restarts
restarts?  That reng straition
still stays?  What happens when
the devices restarts?
>> PETER LEWIS: The
registration stays with
proximity beacon API, and in
your beacon is broadcasting the
same ID after restart, then
you're okay.  With EID, we work
with the clock to determine
which to broadcast.  If it's off
for a short time, we'll cope
with it.  Otherwise, we might
get lost.  Short time is like
hours.
>> So you have to finish the
discovery or scanning, then you
register from your app?
>> PETER LEWIS: Possibly.
Let's talk after.  I'll do one
more question, then I'm going on
>> As a user, is there a way to
unsubscribe from an individual
beacon or from an app for from a
complete project altogether?
>> PETER LEWIS: Yes. With an
app you can uninstall it or you
should dpif your users options.
can dispense it and also dismiss
notifications from a particular
project.
>> Can I do that per beacon?
>> PETER LEWIS: Yes, although
you should try not to think per
beacon.  These are like Cloud
objects now.  That's that.
Anyway, I have to go.  Thank you